madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Directeur général je cherchais
voilà Messieurs les Présidents et Mair
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous procédons ce matin à une
audition pour suite à donner à l'enquête
de la Cour des comptes réalisée à la
demande de notre commission l'
apppplication de l'article 582 de la loi
organique relative au loi de finances
sur l'action de la Direction générale
des finances publiques la DG FIP auprès
du bloc
communal c'est un sujet qui nous
intéresse tout particulièrement au Sénat
alors que la DG FIP est un acteur majeur
du fonctionnement financier des communes
et de leurs établissements publics le
recouvrement des recettes la mise à
disposition des ressources financières
qui en découle le paiement des dépenses
la tenue des comptes et la gestion des
bases cadastrales font notamment partie
de ces
missions on peut pas recevoir la DG FIP
aujourd'hui sans avoir quand même un mot
sur l'action passée durant la crise du
covid et notamment sur la transformation
qui a pu être faite de la DG
FIP qui
finalement a été non seulement
recouvreur d'impôt mais également
quelqu'un qui savez organisé la
distribution de PGE ce qui est qui a été
fait dans des conditions tout à fait
remarquables alors la dgfif s'est
engagée depuis plusieurs années dans la
restructuration de son
réseau avec évidemment comme souvent des
impératifs contradictoires le projet dit
de nouveau réseau de proximité doit à la
fois conduire à une réduction du nombre
de services déconcentrés et se traduire
par une augmentation du nombre de
communes dans lesquelles la DG FIP est
présente ce double impératif
s'accompagne par ailleurs de la mise en
place de nouveaux interlocuteurs pour
les élus locaux comme les conseillers
aux décideurs
locaux alors que la DG FIP joue un rôle
essentiel dans nos territoirees ces
évolutions source d'inquiétude pour de
nombreux élus nous ont conduit à
demander à la Cour des comptes une
évaluation de l'action de la DG FIP
auprès des collectivité territoriale et
en particulier auprès du bloc
communal nous recevons ainsi madame
Karine CAMBI présidente de la première
chambre de la Cour des comptes qui nous
présentera les principales conclusions
de cette enquête le rapporteur spécial
de la mission gestion des finances
publiques Claude nougin nous indiquera
ensuite les principaux enseignements
qu'il en tire et posera les premières
questions pour nous éclairer sur le
sujet mais répondre aux observations de
la Cour et aux remarques du rapporteur
spécial je laisserai ensuite la parole
successivement à Monsieur antoig Manan
directeur par intérim de la Direction
générale des finances publiques Monsieur
Jacques auerti président du chicoval
maire d' viive et administrateur
d'intercommunalité de France ainsi que
Monsieur Bertrand
cornne maire de Marau pr et membre du
conseil d'administration de
l'Association des Maires Ruraux de
France la MRF
évidemment je laisserai ensuite la
parole aux collègues qui le souhaitent
pour vous interroger à l'issu des débats
je demanderai aux membres de la
commission des finances leur accord pour
publier l'enquête remise par la Cour des
comptes je rappelle enfin à tous que
cette audition est retransmise sur le
site internet du Sénat et donc je laisse
désormais la parole à Madame Karine
CAMBI merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
de nous avoir invité ce matin pour vous
présenter ce rapport de la Cour relatif
à l'action de la Direction générale des
finances publiques auprès du bloc
communal sont présents à mes côtés toute
l'équipe tous les membres de l'équipe
Lionel varareille Emmanuel Bichot
Jacques Delmas ainsi que Mathilde Lig
Leloup qui était contreapporteur de ce
rapport et je voudrais les remercier
pour le travail qu'il ont accompli ce
rapport répond monsieur le Président à
la saisine du premier président de la
Cour des comptes Monsieur Pierre
musoscovici qui avait accepté le
principe de ce rapport le 27 février
dernier et il y a eu des échanges avec
le rapporteur de votre commission
monsieur le sénateur Claude nougin et
l'équipe de la première chambre pour
arrêter le cadre général de ce rapport
et la liste des thématiques qu'il
souhaitait que que nous traitions je
voudrais débuter cette présentation par
un point de méthode parmi les raisons
qui vous ont peut-être conduit monsieur
le Président a demandé il y a un an
maintenant à la cour d'étudier comment
la DG FIP mène son action auprès des
communes et plus largement auprès du
bloc communal figurait sans doute une
inquiétude que nous avons perçu la DG
FIP était alors en train de conduire le
resserrement de son réseau déconcentré
qui a abouti à fermer un certain nombre
de petites trésoreries loc
et cela pouvait légitimement susciter
des interrogations peut-être même des
inquiétudes sur le devenir du service
qui est rendu par la DG FIP aux
collectivités dès lors il convenait
d'établir les effets de ce redressement
de ce resserrement pardon en répondant
aux questions suivantes d'abord sur la
mise en œuvre du projet combien de
fermetures de trésorerie ou de services
ont été effectués par la DG PhIP comment
cela s'est-il passé
quelle organisation nouvelle a été mise
en place mais aussi des questions sur
les missions de la DG FIP auprès du bloc
communal ces changements structurels
ont-ils eu un impact sur la qualité du
service rendu au commune notamment bien
sûr celles qui sont situées en zone
rurale pour répondre à ces questions
l'équipe a bien sûr collecter des
informations chiffrées et non chiffrées
mener des entretiens effectuer des
déplacements
nous avons aussi tenu à consulter les
communes et leurs groupements au moyen
d'un sondage qui a permis de recueillir
l'avis des collectivités sur la qualité
du service rendu par la DG FIP nous
avons bien sûr constitué un échantillon
selon les règles en usage sur le plan
statistique de sorte que le résultat qui
est en annexe du rapport peut-être
considéré comme
représentatif après ce point de méthode
je voudrais en venir au fond du sujet et
aborder trois points le premier ce sont
les caractéristiques de l'action de la
DG FIP auprès du bloc communal et la
qualité perçue de cette action en second
lieu l'impact du resserrement du réseau
déconcentré de la DG FIP à travers le
projet intitulé nouveau réseau de
proximité enfin les recommandations qui
permettrai de consolider l'action de la
DG FIP en particulier du point de vue de
la relation avec les Collectiv du bloc
communal je débuterai donc en vous
rappelant les actions menées par la DG
FIP auprès du bloc communal comme
d'ailleurs auprès des autres niveaux de
collectivité et je vous présenterai
également les indicateurs dont nous
disposons pour mesurer l'efficacité et
la manière dont les communes et leur
groupement perçoivent la qualité des
services rendus par la DG FIB comme vous
le savez la DG FIP exerce à la fois des
missions fiscales assiette et
recouvrement des impôts des taxes et des
autres recettes publiques et des
missions de gestion publique contrôle et
paiement des dépenses de l'État des
collectivités territoriales des hôpitaux
et tenu des comptabilités en 2019 le
réseau déconcentré de la dgfi prevant de
ces deux métiers comprenait 3500
services
3499 exactement implanté sur le
territoire national et leur nombre
devait diminuer à
1761 à l'issue du
projet qui a été engagé par la DG FIP le
projet nouveau réseau de proximité soit
une baisse de près de la moitié à
l'horizon
2025 au plan national les il y a à peu
près 93000 agents aujourd'hui dans cette
administration et 85 % donc c'est
considérable travaille dans le réseau
déconcentrés la DG FIP est un un acteur
majeur du fonctionnement financier des
collectivités et de leurs établissements
publics puisque comme je l'ai dit elle
recouvre les recettes des collectivités
met à disposition les ressources
financières qui en découlent payent
leurs dépenses tient leur compte et gère
aussi les bases cadastrales ces missions
prennent d'autant plus d'importance
auprès du bloc communal et
singulièrement des communes rurales que
celles-ci dans leur grande majorité ne
disposent pas des ressources humaines
euh bien toujours bien formé dans ces
domaines qui sont techniques et j'y
reviendrai d'ailleurs à la fin de mon
propos alors si on entre un peu plus
dans le détail de ces missions
s'agissant des recettes fiscales que
l'État recouvre pour le comptees des
collectivités les montants versés en
2022 aux communes syndicats et EPCI au
titre des avances de fiscalité directe
locale se sont élevés à plus de 69
milliards d'euros les impôts directs
locaux sur rô c'est-à-dire
principalement les taxes foncières les
taxes d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires et la cotisation foncière
des entreprises sont la principale
ressource du bloc communal en 2022 avec
45,8 milliards d'euros s' ajoute
d'autres ressources comme les fractions
de TVA qui leur sont affectées ou les
impôts autoliquidé tel que la cveae qui
comme vous le savez est en cours de
suppression
le sondage qui a été effectué par la
Cour à l'occasion de cette enquête
confirme une bonne perception par les
collectivités à propos du respect du
calendrier de versement les communes
regrettent cependant de ne pas toujours
disposer leors de l'élaboration de leur
budget du montant des dotations qui leur
seront attribuées ces informations
pouvant leur être communiqué assez
tardivement alors que le budget est déjà
élaboré de ce point de vue les modifi
des indicateurs financiers servant à la
répartition des dotations et des fonds
de péréquation introduites par les lois
de finances initial pour 2021 et 2022
suscite en particulier un fort besoin
d'explication de la part des
collectivité enfin s'agissant du
recouvrement des recettes non fiscales
et des amendes l'une des associations
d'élu consultés par la Cour nous a fait
part d'un besoin accru d'échange
d'information
entre les collectivités et les services
de la DG FIP bien en amont de la demande
d'admission en nonvaleur des créance
devenu
irrecouvrable ce besoin d'échange
d'information ressort également sur un
autre aspect majeur de l'intervention de
l' DG FIP auprès du bloc communal c'est
celui du paiement de leur dépenses et de
la tenue de leur compte si les délais de
paiement des dépenses par le comptable
n'appellent pas de commentaire
particulier la tenue des comptes fait
actuellement l'objet de projets de
modernisation très structurant tel que
le compte financier unique le passage à
la nomenclature M57
ou l'expérimentation de la certification
des comptes locaux et euh ces points
révèlent des marges de progrès ce point
cette certification a révélé d'ailleurs
la Cour a fait un rapport sur ce sujet
des marges euh assez importantes de
fiabilisation des comptes plus des 2
tiers des communes interrogées par la
Cour expriment ainsi une attente forte
d'accompagnement par la DG FIB sur le
passage à la
M57 la tenue des bases cadastrales et
leur fiabilisation constiue également
une mission centrale des services
fonciers des directions départementales
des finances publiques la DG FIP a mis
en place un service en ligne qui
s'appelle gérer mes biens immobiliers
les particuliers doivent ainsi mettre à
jour depuis 2023 leur situation par
rapport à l'occupation de ces biens et
d'après la DG FIP la première mise en
œuvre de cette obligation s'est traduite
par un ressaut important des bases de
taxes d'habitation notamment sur les
résidences secondairire et dans une
moindre mesure sur la taxe d'habitation
sur les logements vacants ce ressaut a
été notifié sans explication suffisante
à l'automne 2023 aux collectivités
locales et il relève dans une proportion
qui reste à déterminer d'une
régularisation des bases avec un effet
pérenne ou bien de déclarations erronées
le gouvernement s'est engagé à
identifier et à corriger rapidement les
erreurs qui seront à la charge de l'État
une information rapide des collectivités
et cependant en tout état de cause
nécessaire pour identifier le caractère
pérenes ou non de ces recettes
supplémentaires sur ce sujet les
collectivités interrogées par la Cour
demeure en attente d'une amélioration
des services proposés par
l'administration fiscale en matière
foncière et cadastrale notamment en
terme de délis de réponse et d'échange
d'information et cela vaut d'ailleurs
dans les deux sens dans les petites
communes les maires ont souvent une
meilleure connaissance que laadg FIB du
tissu bâti et peuvent contribuer eux
aussi à une fiabilisation des bases j'en
viens maintenant au deème point le
resserrement en cours du réseau
territorial de la DG FIP à l'occasion du
projet NRP nouveau réseau de proximité
le 6 juin 2019 le ministre chargé des
comptes publics a annoncé la mise en
œuvre d'une je cite géographie revisitée
des implantations de la DG FIP ce
nouveau réseau ce ce nouveau projet par
pardon a été renommé nouveau réseau de
proximité il répondait à un double
constat tout d'abord l'accueil des
usagers notamment des particuliers
devait être mod is comp tenu en
particulier du développement des outils
numériques deuxème constat les
réorganisations précédente du réseau de
la DG FIP qui avait été marqué chaque
année par la fermeture de petite
trésoreries local ne se situait pas dans
un plan et un calendrier d'ensemble il
n'y avait pas donc une visibilité sur
les résultats qui souhaitait qui était
souhaité dans ce domaine les objectifs
chiffrés étaient les suivants au total
le nom nombre de communes comportant une
présence même temporaire de la DG FIP
devait initialement passer d'un peu
moins de 2000 points à plus de
2570 à fin 2023 c'était l'objectif fixé
dans le contrat d'objectif et de moyen
de la BG FIP ce qui représentait une
augmentation de 30 %. nous pouvons dire
que cet objectif est aujourd'hui dépassé
puisque fin 2022 il y a
2975 communes qui comportait une
présence de la DG FIP et ce nombre
devait passer environ
3000 à la fin de l'année 2023 peut-être
monsieur Magnan aura-t-il des des
chiffres plus actualisés parallèlement
le nombre de postes comptables devait
lui diminuer de moitié passant de 3500 à
1760 61 exactement à l'issue des
opérations de réorganisation prévu de
façon échelonnée jusqu'en
2025 cet objectif a presque été atteint
nous le verrons et de nouvelles
structures les services de gestion
comptable regroupent désormais les
anciennes trésoreries local un nouveau
métier a été créé celui de conseiller
aux décideurs locaux pour apporter aux
élus un soutien dans les domaines
financier fiscal budgétaire et comptable
cette apparente contradiction entre le
resserrement du réseau comptable et
l'augmentation du nombre de communes
comportant une présence de la DG FIP
tient au au développement des points de
proximité dans les espaces France servic
2600 en novembre 2023 et en mairie 400
permanence
comptabilisé les usagers ont désormais
la possibilité également de régler leur
dettte fiscale dans le réseau des
buraliste avec 1000 15000 points pardon
à la mi-octobre 2023 ce réseau n'étant
pas comptabilisé dans les chiffres que
je vous ai donné c'est normal parmi les
les points de présence de la DG FIB je
voudrais dire un mot de la la démarche
engagée par la DG FIB dans la
préparation et la mise en œuvre de ce
projet car elle repose sur trois points
qui me semblent intéressant de souligner
c'est une démarche qui est à la fois
globale pluriannuelle et concertée
pluriannuelle parce qu'elle s'appuie sur
des cibles qui ont été chiffré
d'implantation de nouveaux services
jusqu'en
2026 l'essentiel des réorganisations est
cependant intervenu entre 2020 et 2023
donc assez rapidement et seul quelques
opérations immobilières encore complexes
restent à mener en région il y a une
carte dans le rapport c'est la carte
numéro 1 je pense qu'on l'a sur les
diapos merci ces cibles ont fait l'objet
d'une large concertation avec les élus
locaux les organisations syndicales et
l'ensemble des agents de la DG
FIB des cartes des implantations
projetées ont situé le socle de la
concertation qui a été conduite par les
directeurs locaux de la DG FIP en lien
avec les préfets la concertation avec
les agents et les organisations
syndicales a également été menée à bien
même si les organisations syndicales se
sont déclarés opposés à ce projet dans
la mesure où il entraînaiit des
suppressions d'emploi les schémas cibles
ont ensuite pu être formalisé dans des
chartes départementales ces chartes qui
ont été préparé par le directeur
départemental des finances publiques et
présenté aux élus n'ont pas été signés
dans tous les départements mais la
concertation a néanmoins permis de faire
évoluer assez significativement les
projets initiaux avec la création de 180
accueils de proximité supplémentairire
et des services propres de la DG FIP en
nombre plus important qu'envisagé
initialement plus 15 % si l'on tient
compte des antennes créées le déploi du
nouveau réseau de proximité donc en
passe d'être achevé et respecte
globalement les objectifs de la réforme
et le calendrier prévu le taux de
resserrement du réseau qui avait pour
objectif initial dans la première
version de la carte de service de
supprimer la moitié des structures par
rapport à 2019 se situe un peu en
desessà de cet objectif puisque la
diminution n'est pas de 50 % mais de 42
% et la concertation avec les élus a
permis de maintenir des services dans
des territoires peu densément peuplés ou
de créer des antennes qui peuvent être
provisoires ou pérenes il y en a 53
antennes provisoires et 263 antennes
pérennes ces réorganisations ont permis
aussi de regrouper les effectifs dans
des structures de taille plus
importantes symétriquement le nombre de
structures de toute petite taille à
diminuer ce qui renforce la capacité de
la DG FIP à garantir sur l'ensemble du
territoire une qualité de service plus
homogène il y avait en 2016 plus de 600
services de moins de 5
agents seul une centaine de services de
moins de 5 agents subsisteront après la
réforme dont 60 % seront des antenes de
services plus importants en parallèle la
participation de la DGFiP au réseau
France service est aussi conformme à ce
qui était prévu fin 2023 sa présence
devrait être effective dans plus de
2600 maisons labéisé ces espaces
couvrent majoritairement les zones
rurales et les quartiers prioritaires de
la politique de la ville je voudrais
mettre en regard ces résultats chiffrés
globalement conformes avec les objectifs
avec la perception des collectivités
puisque d'après notre sondage les
communes rurales interrogées par la Cour
exprime des fortes réticences vis-à-vis
de cette nouvelle carte des
implantations et seul 31 % d'entre elles
considèent qu'elle est tout à fait ou
plutôt pertinente en effet la petite la
fermeture des petites trésoreries
locales a été perçu comme un symptôme du
retrait de l'État sur les territoires
dans un contexte de tension d'ailleurs
observé sur le recrutement et la
formation des secrétaires de mairie dès
lors ce resserrement du réseau doit être
mis en perspective avec la qualité du
service rendu et ça perception avec par
les collectivités locales mais ce point
ne pourra être pleinement évalué qu'au
terme du déploiement des conseillers aux
décideurs locaux et des services de
gestion locale et avec un tout petit peu
de recul par rapport à la création de
ces nouveaux services et nouveaux
conseillers s'agissant des conseillers
au décideurs locaux les nominations ont
progressé à un rythme soutenu de 2020 à
2023 917 agents sont en poste en
décembre 2023 et la cible est fixée à
993 CDL sur l'ensemble du territoire
national donc on n est pas très loin
toutes les collectivités du bloc
communal devrai à terme disposer d'un
CDL référent celui-ci pouvant cependant
être l'interlocuteur de plusieurs EPCI
le sondage réalisé par la Cour indique
dors et déjà que les CDL c'estes
conseillers au décideurs locaux sont
bien identifiés par les collectivité 90
% d'entre elles identifient leur CDL
notamment en milieu rural où ils jouent
un rôle important auprès des secrétaires
de mairie leur action de conseil en
matière budgétaire fiscale comptable est
apprécié par 90 % des collectivités
interrogées au terme de notre enquête et
j'en viens donc au 3è et dernier point
de cette présentation nous constatons
que la DGFiP a engagé une transformation
profonde de son réseau et que plusieurs
points méritent une attention
particulière s'il est encore prématuré
de dresser le bilan définitif des
opérations de
restructuration l'ambition de la réforme
son calendrier la démarche de
concertation et l'ampleur des
transformation menée mérit d'être relevé
les collectivités interrogées par la
Cour dans le cadre de la présente
enquête mettent néanmoins en avant des
points d'attention sur la qualité du
service rendu par la DG FIB dans le
cadre de ce réseau serré les attentes
sont particulièrement importantes dans
les communes rurales qui s'appuyent sur
des équipes restreintes et sans en faire
une recommandation en tant que telle
nous constatons une très forte attente
en matière de formation des secrétaires
de mairie sur les sujets budgétaires
fiscaux et financiers dans un contexte
où il y a des difficultés de recrutement
importantes de ces personnels qui sont
clés notamment dans les communes de
moins de 3500 habitants nous adressons
trois recommandations au ministère de
l'économie et des finances que je vous
présente rapidement la première consiste
à réaliser dès 2024 dès cette année un
bilan du déploiement des conseillers au
décideurs locaux et de leur articulation
avec les services de gestion comptable
au regard des attentes des élus et de
leur relations avec eux nous avons
constater que la nouvelle organisation
pouvait donner lieu parfois des
malentendus ou des incompréhensions sans
doute temporaire du côté des
collectivités qui est le bon
interlocuteur est-ce que c'est le
conseiller au auprès des commune ou bien
le nouveau service de gestion comptable
quel est le rôle exact de chacun ces
ambiguïés tiennent forcément au
caractère encore récent de la réforme
mais néanmoins il y a des pratiques
variables d'un territoire à l'autre et
endresser le bilan permettra de mieux
cadrer l'action de chacun et permettra
aux élus d'avoir une vision plus clair
de du rôle de leurs interlocuteurs et de
ce que ils peuvent attendre d'eux la
deuxième recommandation vise à conforter
la participation de la DG FIP aux espace
France service cette participation est
appréciée par les collectivités
interrogées par la cour mais elle peut
être confortée sur plusieurs points
notamment l'accueil d'espace France
service dans les locaux des directions
départemental des finances publiques ce
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
l'affectation de plus d'agent la DG FIP
comme animateur des espaces France
servic et le réexamin des niveaux
d'engagement en fonction des besoins
exprimés qui peuvent être très variables
évidemment d'un espace à l'autre enfin
notre troisème recommandation consiste à
compléter les outils de recensement de
la satisfaction des usagers avec des
enquêtes qui permettraient de mesurer
lesulté d'accès des populations les plus
éloignées euh notamment euh qui ont des
difficulté d'accès aux outils
dématérialisés parce qu'il y a quand
même une vraie difficulté dans ce
domaine notamment dans les territoires
ruraux mais pas uniquement et la DG FIB
dispose de plusieurs outils de ce type
mais nous avons constaté que les usagers
qui sont sondés sont ceux quand même qui
sont souvent le plus à l'aise avec les
outils numériques et avec le contact
avec l'administration en général ils ne
peuvent donc suffire à prendre la mesure
des difficultés que peuvent rencontrer
l'ensemble emble des administrés et en
particulier ceux qui n'ont pas accès au
service d'accueil de la DG FIP et il y a
toujours cette notion d'aller vers les
populations les plus éloignées qui
restent extrêmement importantes enfin
afin de connaître les nouveaux guichets
d'accueil de
proximité pour les
populations les plus éloignées des
outils numériques une campagne de
communication spécifique pourrait
s'avérer utile voilà Monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur général
les principales analyses et
recommandations de la Cour sur ce sujet
et je suis bien sûr avec mon équipe à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci pour l'exposé merci de
l'avoir fait dans le délai
imparti merci de ce rapport je vais
donner tout de suite la parole à notre
rapporteur spécial monsieur Claude
nougin qui avait souhaité bien entendu
escaliter la sisine de la cour sur cette
action de la DG FIP auprès du bloc
communal chers collègues vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président madamees et
Messieurs euh monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues je
commencerai en remerciant la Cour des
comptes pour ses travaux d'abord pour m
avoir associés et ils sont
particulièrement utiles pour apprécier
l'action de la DG FIP auprès de nos
communes et de nos intercommunalité
c'est un sujet du quotidien pour les
maires et les sénateurs de province et
les provinces profondes comme on dit à
Paris le savent et euh qu' soit élu zone
rurale et même zone urbaine en tout
premier lieu je tiens à à souligner le
caractère innovant de l'enquête menée
par la Cour qui s'est en partie appuyé
sur un sondage auprès d'un échantillon
représentatif du bloc communal il me
semble que c'est une méthode de travail
inédite et qui gagerit à être généralisé
dans l'évaluation de nos politiques
publiques et de nos services public il
est encore trop rare aujourd'hui de
demander leur avis au premiers concernés
et de recueillir leurs éléments
d'appréciation deux éléments ont rendu
ce sondage d'autant plus nécessaire
d'une part nous ne disposons aujourd'hui
que des évaluations conduites par la DG
FIP elle-même sur la qualité des
services qu'elle rend l'activitéérieur
territorial bien sûr nous ne doutons pas
de l'impartialité de ces évaluations
mais il est touour utile de pouvoir
disposer d'une autre source
d'information en l'espèce et peut-être
sans surprise les résultats de la DG FIP
et de la Cour des comptes sont
cohérentes et très positifes à une ou
deux exceptions prê sur lesquelles je
reviendrai d'autre part ce sondage
intervient à un moment tout à fait
opportun
alors que la DG FIP qui remplit des
missions essentielles pour les communes
et les intercommunalités est en pleine
transformation on a parfois l'impression
que c'est le cas depuis sa création et
qu' n'y a jamais eu de véritable
stabilisation il m'a paraît plutôt que
sont des changements qui prennent du
temps entre la restructuration du réseau
et la mise en place de nouveaux
interlocuteurs pour les élus locaux la
Cour des comptes porte un regard
globalement positif sur la
restructuration engagée par la DG FIP
sur la méthode employée ainsi que sur sa
mise en œuvre je le souligne c'est assez
rare et je vais revenir sur chacun de
ces
points sur la restructuration d'abord la
DG FIP c'est près de 79000 agents en
service déconcentré en service
déconcentré je crois que vous avez dit
93000 au
global environ 1800 postes comptables et
une présence dans près de 3000 commune
ainsi la diminution du nombre de
services déconcentrés de plus de 50 % en
prévision entre 2019 et 2026
s'accompagne d'une augmentation du
nombre de points de contact que ce soit
à travers des permanences dans les
mairies ou dans les espaces France
service si ces deux évolutions peuvent
apparaître contradictoires elles me
semblent de bonne politique les usagers
doivent pouvoir avoir un point de
contact proche de chez eux mais il n pas
forcément nécessaire d'avoir une
trésorerie par
intercommunalité c'est ce qui avait été
proposé par le ministre du Budget à
l'époque ce principe apparaît en effet
un peu trop rigide alors que les
intercommunalités sont de taille très
différentes si je prends l'exemple de
mon département il y a nef
intercommunalité il y a une trésorerie
pour les neuf il y a une agglomération
de 110000
habitants et il y a un trésorerie pour
une pour une intercommunauté de 5000
habitants
donc la plus petite fait 5000 la plus
grande fait 110000 et on dit il faut une
trésorerie par
intercommunaité chercher l'erreur
parfois il faut s'adapter à la réalité
du terrain par ailleurs augmenter le
nombre moyen d'agents par service c'est
aussi s'assurer que les départs en
retraite ne remettront pas en cause la
pérenité du poste comptable sur la
méthode ensuite chaque année lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de finan et
des crédit àoué à DGFiP nous parlons de
son nouveau réseau de proximité cette
expression marketing devrait refléter le
changement de méthode intervenue en 2019
fini la restructuration l'aveugle et au
coup par coup place à la concertation
avec les élus locaux les agents et les
organisations professionnelles les
résultats de la cour des de l'enquête de
la Cour des comptes tendent à nous
montrer que le changement de méthode
annoncé à grand renfort de communication
par le gouvernement de l'époque a bien
eu lieu pour une fois la concertation
n'est pas restée un 20 mot la signature
des chartes avec les départements et les
intercommunalités s'est traduit par la
création de 180 accueils de proximité
supplémentaire par rapport au schéma
initialement
envisagé la cour cite les exemples du
Finistère et des pirénées atlantiques
madame la Présidente cambille pourra
sans n sans doute nous en dire plus sur
ce point et Messieurs Oberti et
hochcorn nous donner l'appréciation
intercommunauté de France et de
l'association des Maes
ruraux de France sur cette coopération
j'en viens enfin à la mise en œuvre de
ce nouveau
réseau les résultats du sondage sont à
cet égard très révélateurs alors que les
communes se montrent globalement
satisfaites des services rendus par la
DG FIP les résultats s'inversent
lorsqu'elles sont interrogées sur la
nouvelle cartographie du réseau de la DG
FIP seul 32 % des communes rurales sont
satisfaits de la nouvelle carte des
implantations des services de gestion
comptable et 53 % des commune non rurale
l'association des maères ruraux de
France fera peut-être écho à
l'explication qui me semble devoir être
faite de ce
résultat pour les petites communes en
particulier la fermeture d'une
trésorerie c'est un nouveau service de
l'État qui s'en va c'est parfois un
drame dans une toute petite commune un
nouveau signe du retrait de l'État pour
les communes rurales qui ne disposent
pas de service entiers dédiés à la
gestion administrative et financière
beaucoup reposent sur les secrétaires de
mairie qui ont l'impression de perdre un
expert de
proximité l'installation des conseillers
au décideurs locaux les fameux CDL doit
pour partie permettre de répondre à ses
préoccupations et de contrebalancer ce
sentiment
d'abandon les conseillers aux décideurs
locaux ont vocation à devenir les
interlocuteurs privilégiés des
ordonnateurs des collectivités
territoriales chaque commune disposerait
d'un conseiller référent un conseiller
pouvant être interlocuteur de plusieurs
communes et intercommunalités
917 CDL était en poste à la fin de
l'année 2023 la cible vous l'AVE dit
madame la Présidente et de 993 à l'issue
du déploiement de ce nouveau
réseau le sondage mené par la Cour des
comptes illustre le haut niveau de
satisfaction des communes à l'égard des
CDL qui pourrait toutefois être encore
plus présent auprès des secrétair de
mairie pour l'élaboration du budget
notamment je note toutois que lorsque le
projet des CDL nous avait été présenté
je pense que c'était en 2019 il y a de
quelques années je me souviens très bien
parce je l'ai entendu moi-même je l'ai
pas lu dans la presse je l'ai entendu de
la part du ministre 1200 conseillers
étaient prévus et
annoncé je souhaiterai monsieur Maillan
si vous pouvez nous expliquer cet écart
euh si parce que c'était une cible 2200
avec la bonne cible et000 ou ou
parce que vous n'avez plus les budgets
pour aller jusqu'à 12 donc euh c'est
c'est une question puisque c'est quand
même 20 % d'écart également la Cour des
comptes soulligne dans dans son enquête
de fores disparités en termes de charge
de travail entre conseillers suivant
leur affectation la DG FIP partage-telle
ce
constat j'en terminerai enfin avec les
services rendus par DGFiP aux communes
et aux intercommunalités en m'attardant
sur deux points de vigilance le premier
concerne la gestion des bases
cadastrales ça
c'est un maronnier comme on dit dans la
presse les les communes ne sont pas
pleinement satisfaites des services
rendus par la DG FIP en matière
cadastrale et
foncière l'association des des des Maes
ruraux intercommunaité de France
pourront le
confirmer l'actualisation des bases
cadastrales n'est pas un problème
nouveau pour le bloc communal et c'est
un sujet ancien sur lequel on ne
progresse que très
lentement la DG FIP envisage-t-elle de
proposer de nouveaux services aux
communes dans ce domaine je m'interroge
quel bilan provisoire pouvez-vous tirer
du projet foncier
innovant notamment avec les difficulté
rencontrer cet été mois de juin c'était
un affaolement général dans dans
certaines région autour de l'interface
en ligne gérer mes bien
immobiliers le second point de vigilance
concerne la satisfaction des usagers
au-delà des MRES et des communes la trè
recommandation de la Cour des comptes
reprend un propos que nous énonçons
chaque année dans nos rapports
budgétaires la dématérialisation ne doit
pas conduire à laisser de côté les
publics les plus éloignés du numérique
aller vers le numérique c'est bien aller
trop vite c'est moins bien Madame la
président comie pourriez-vous nous
préciser le propos de la Cour des
comptes sur les SEP aspects monsieur
manant qu'avez-vous mis en place au sein
de la DG FIP pour répondre à ces
préoccupations je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur spécial
pour cette analyse du rapport de la
cours et pour les demandes
complémentaires que vous formulez je
vais donc maintenant céder la parole à
antoig Magnan donc directeur par inérim
de la DG FIP pour bien vouloir réagir à
la fois à l'enquête de la Cour et à
cette rapport et ses quelques
conclusions et aux questions du
rapporteur spécial
merci merci pardon merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs et monsieur le rapporteur
de mon budget en particulier auquel je
dois naturellement une révérence
particulière messieurs les les élus et
les et les présidents madame la
Présidente de la première chambre
mesdames messieurs merci pour cette
invitation merci monsieur le Président
d'avoir pris l'initiative de faire
travailler la Cour des comptes sur sur
ce sujet qui pour nous naturellement est
très important et
qui met en exerg à la fois comme vous
l'z avez eu l'amabilité de le dire dans
votre propos introductif la proximité la
la densité des interrelations
quotidiennes entre la direction générale
des finances publiques l'administration
que je représente ce matin devant vous
et l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales au premier
chef les communes et les
intercommunalités et on pourrait élargir
naturellement le propos aux autres aux
autres collectivités territoriales
auprès desquelles nous nous efforçons de
rendre un service
identique merci madame la Présidente
pour la présentation que vous avez
faite qui euh comme d'ailleurs
l'indiquer votre votre rapport écrit et
et ce n'est pas si banal de la part de
la Cour des comptes notamment lorsque
elle s'adresse à cette administration
mais en exergue un bilan que Monsieur le
le rapporteur vous avez qualifié
globalement
positif si l'expression n'était pas
datée ou spécifiquement marqué j'aurais
j'aurais qualifié de positif notamment
dans l'échelle de valeur de la Cour des
comptes et je m'en réjouis et je me
réjouis de le
partager devant vous je vais je vais
revenir et je vais essayer d'être bref
dans ma présentation générale pour aller
rapidement au en réponse aux questions
que les uns les autres avaient bien
voulu nous
adresser en 2019 on a changé de pied de
cap dans la manière dont on organise
notre réseau et notamment nos évolutions
territoriales pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord la première était un constat
d'un modèle à bout de souffle dans
l'organisation de son
évolution modèle à bout de souffle par
le fait
que d'abord les les diminutions d'emploi
considérabl tel que voté par la
représentation nationale
euh qui se caractérise par une
diminution de nos effectifs de près de
40 % en un peu plus de 20 ans
nécessitait une capacité pour la qualité
du service public rendu pour la capacité
à mobiliser des équipes qui euh avaient
du mal à se projeter dans le dans le
court le moyen et même le long terme
dans la finalité de leur mission et dans
l'endroit où ils allaient l'exercer
nécessitait un changement de
cap
et nous avons réussi à nous placer dans
une logique pluriannuelle que pour des
raisons diverses pré dans les périodes
précédentes nous n'arrivions pas à
mettre en œuvre et nous raisonnions
suivant un principe de stricte annualité
qui
organisait une identification d'un
certain nombre de trésoreries qui
pouvaiit être fermé c'était un une des
sources d'économie d'emploi que nous
étions dans l'obligation de mettre en
œuvre ce n'était de très loin pas la
seule et donc on réussi à se placer dans
une perspective pluriannuelle on fonde
cette ce changement de pied notamment
dans les activités auou Bénéfic des
collectivités territoriales sur l'idée
d'un changement assez profond
d'organisation les missions de
d'exécution comptable en recette en
dépenses sont concentrés dans des
équipes
dansifié des équipes densifié qui
assurent une capacité à qui même
apportent garantie d'assurer le le
service public dans la durée sans que
les les les éventuels rabots successifs
ne viennent mettre en en cause la
pérennité de des implantations et des
équipes et puis on crée un nouveau
métier il est conseillés aux décideurs
locaux destinés
à dans le meilleur des cas à garantir la
la qualité et la proximité du conseil en
matière financière de au sens-l large au
bénéfice des des collectivités des élus
et des des secrétaires de mairie je dis
dans le meilleur des cas la maintenir et
dans nombre de cas m-t-il semblé
d'améliorer cette qualité d'améliorer la
disponibilité des équipes en
charge c'est un métier fondamentalement
nouveau visant à dédier des agents à
cette seule mission qui auparavant
n'était pas exercé à pleintemps par par
les trésoriers de la Direction générale
des finances publ nous en sommes à 1000
l'état investi 1000 emplois dans une
administration qui elle-même est en
réduction au bénéfice de cette mission
et au bénéfice de ces interlocuteurs du
quotidien de cette administration et des
Français l'objectif initial de 1200 a
été effectivement un petit peu revu à la
baisse mais 1000 c'est l'obj c'est la
situation du moment je n'excu pas que
nous continuion à monter et le rapport
de la Cour des comptes les les
interpellations des uns et des autres
peuvent mettre en exerg le
besoin de faire évoluer généralement à
la hausse dans la mesure des moyens que
la représentation nationale nous donnera
ou de de peaufiner dans tel ou tel
endroit lorsque les collectivités
mettent en exergue une insuffisance de
disponibilité des agents qui sont mis à
disposition de cette mission donc pour
répondre directement à la question de du
rapporteur nous en sommes là et nous
pouvons aller au-delà si nous
identifions un besoin réel ou ou une
insuffisance de qualité disponibilité et
si nous arrivons à mettre en place en
face la ressource présente de qualité
j'ai toujours considéré qu'il valait
mieux avoir un tout petit peu moins de
personnes dédiées avec un degré
d'expertise et disponibilité
supérieure que plus plus de personnes
qui euh n'apporteraient pas un conseil
du niveau de celui que vous êtes en
droit
d'attendre vous avez bien voulu madame
la Présidente
euh indiquer que la méthodologie était
nouvelle dans la projection à long terme
dans la conduite de la concertation à la
fois nationale et
locale les premiers les premières
semaines ont été un peu chahutées euh
dans la capacité que nous avions à
rendre crédible cette ambition
dans la capacité de conviction sur place
de de chacun des
élus moi je constate aujourd'hui que non
seulement il y avait une ambition qui
était forte et qui bénéficié des
qualificatifs positifs que vous avvez
bien voulu lui donner mais que en plus
la réalisation est là ce qui ne va pas
toujours de soi surtout quand il y a le
covid au milieu et semble-t-il les
résultats sont là et ce point mérite
qu'on s'y arrête quelques instants
vous avez donné les résultats des
sondages que vous pratiquez pour pour
pour rassurer monsieur nouin je vous
indique que nous nous interrogeons de
manière systématique l'ensemble des
l'ensemble des maires depuis la mise en
place de cette réforme sur la qualité
perçue du conseil au décideurs locaux et
du service de gestion comptable et que
les résultats sont positifs à 80 % pour
les services de gestion comptable et à
un peu systématiquement plus de 85 %
depuis le début sur les conseils au
décideurs locaux donc nous pratiquons
non pas le sondage mais l'interrogation
générale c'est pas un échantillon c'est
c'est c'est la totale si vous me
permettez expression et dans nos
interrelations de sur un sur les champs
plus larges de mission c'est pas nous
qui menons des sondages c'est
actuellement la direction la Délégation
interministérielle à la transformation
publique qui a repris un dispositif qui
est en place depuis une quinzaine
d'années c'est-à-dire
que nous enfin un institut de sondage
interroge chaque année un panel de
Français sur leur relation avec les
services publics de l'État de manière
générale c'est le baromètre dit de
l'ouvrier qui est rendu public chaque
année au printemps
et donc ce ce sondage et ces résultats
sont publics sont sur une durée très
longue qui permet de mesurer des
évolutions et une des caractéristique et
que l'administration que je représente
devant vous ce matin se trouvait
depuis à peu près l'origine et notamment
dans les 5 dernières années identifié
comme étant l'administration si je peux
dire préférée des Français il partage ce
premier cette place sur le podium avec
la police
nationale
et le devoir de loyauté vis-à-vis des
collègues fait que je n'indiquerai pas
publiquement qui sont ceux qui sont
moins bien classés que nous et je laisse
celles et ceux d'entre vous qui ont la
curiosité de le regarder aller voir donc
cette Pr du sondage elle est réalisée
elle est systématique elle est
structurante pour nous parce que je
partage pleinement avec vous l'idée que
se fonder sur un miroir déformant ou un
mauvais maquillage ou l'image qu'on
souhaiterait voir de soi-même c'est la
garantie de billet de réflexion
et de décisions qui sont par principe
très mal
orienté
donc je je vous remercie d'avoir bien
voulu connaître qu'il avait une ambition
et une démarche à la fois innovante et
et plutôt positive et j'insiste vous en
avez donné quelques résultats sur le
fait que à nos yeux les résultats de
cette de cette de cette profonde
évolution organisationnelles des métiers
méthodologiques et dans le fond de nos
interrelations avec les élus ont été
tenu et ont été mis en œuvre et dans le
délis et avec le covid au
milieu c'est quoi la la suite
2024 pour la première fois depuis ben le
début du millénaire les effectifs de la
Direction générale des finances
publiques vont être en évolution
positive quoique légère 2025 même
situation notre objectif dans ces deux
années il est très clair c'est la
consolidation consolidation des
organisations consolidation des
méthodologies de travail consolidation
des
résultats et consolidé ça veut pas
dire on ne bouge plus et tout va mieux
c'est mieux mesurer mieux formé et
améliorer les éléments et les situations
qui sont en situation de posere
difficulté je viens du de ce fait un
certain aux recommandations de la Cour
et et aux questionnement de de Monsieur
Mougin qui dans le fond sont sont
convergentss
euh le bilan du déploiement des conseils
au décideurs locaux j'allais vous dire
euh vous nous l'avez présenté et chaque
année nous le faisons et nous allons
continuer à le faire non pas pour nous
englorifier mais pour mesurer les
éventuelles alertes pour je vous dis
peaufiner s'il y a lieu les cartes
locales
et veiller à
une capacité de s d'appropriation de
notre organisation effective par les
interlocuteurs pour le compte desquels
nous travaillons ça signifie quelques
éléments qui sont très pratiques très
topiques et euh que chaque fois que je
suis en déplacement sur le sur le
terrain je enfin dont je m'enquère à
chaque fois que je suis en déplacement
sur le terrain
est-ce
que le maire l'adjoint en
finance le secrétaire de mairie à le 06
de son conseil au décideurs locaux la
capacit il me semble que ça c'est
l'indicateur de de vérité de l'existence
et de la fluidité de la relation au-delà
de tout ce qu'on raconte sur des
conventions
sur des partenariats sur des points de
rencontre réguliers si je peux
parce que on a suffisamment de confiance
dans pour qu'on se donne pour qu'on se
donne notre numéro puisque si j'ai le 06
de interlocuteur ça veut dire que
lui-même a le mien alors c'est que on a
réussi on a encore mieux réussi si on
s'en sert
effectivement ça c'est le premier point
que je que je voulais mentionner le
second point pour aller sur les sujets
directement liés aux finances du bloc
communal vous nous avez interrogé sur
l'état des bas cadastrales et sur le les
avancées du projet dit du foncier
innovant nous avons je crois présenté
publiquement je crois que nous vous
avons présenté nous avons présenté à
plusieurs membres de la commission des
finances les premiers résultats de de ce
dispositif qui très schématiquement
euh vise par des dispositifs
d'intelligence artificielle internalisé
par dans mes équipes informatiques à
mesurer les écarts entre la photographie
aérienne faite par l'Institut
géographique national du territoire de
chaque commune avec la réalité du plan
cadastral de les mettre en face l'un de
l'autre et si je puux dire de jouer au
jeu des 7 erreurs nous avons commencé
par ce qui était à la fois le plus
simple et le plus topique les piscines
on en a trouvé plus de
200000 le la réévaluation des base de
taxes foncière qui découle de ce simple
élément là assure un gain annuel
d'environ 50 million d'euros aux
collectivités territoriales nous
élargissons nous commençons par
identifier des bâtis isolés il y en
a-t-il beaucoup dans quelques teritoire
donc c'est des des constructions toute
seule dans dans un terrain dans de dans
deux départements d'expérimentation la
Haute Savoie etev nous en avons trouvé
très peu c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
veut dire que il y a peu de
constructions importantes de cette
nature là qui ont été réalisés sans
permis de construire on va on va le
généraliser mais le le gain en attendre
est heureusement faible le cadastre est
quand même bien tenu et les permis de
construire sont délivrés à propos
troisième point sur lequel nous allons
nous focaliser qui sera plus compliqué
sur lequel nous allons avancer
prudemment pour ne pas faire de bêtises
de notre côté et ne pas susciter de
rejet par des des interventions
intempestives de notre part mais on sait
bien que ça représente une réalité
sociologique forte des des
agrandissements de bâtil une veréranda
un
étage une pièce en plus qui on qui ont
été rajouté et qui aurait été rajouté
sans permis de construire et qui aurait
dû de ce fait entrer dans le champ de la
taxe Roncière qui n'y sont pas pour des
raisons diverses et variées on va pas
aller chipoter pour pour quelques pour
quelques demi
m² il faut qu'on soit sûr de nous
euh parce que si on se trompe ça va pas
ça va pas bien se passer mais donc il
faut qu'on ait le temps de peaufiner nos
modèles de faire des expérimentations
qui nous garantissent que ce que nous
identifions est cohérent pertinent et
met en exerg un manque un manque à
gagner réel au bénéfice des des au
détriment plutôt d'ailleurs qui sera
comblé ensuite au bénéfice des du bloc
communal c'est la suite des actions nous
sommes en train de faire des l'ensemble
des travaux de de vérification du fait
que nous allons arriver à hauteur de
cette ambition je le
souhaite je suis sûr que le bloc que que
les collectivités seront contentes de du
russement des bases mais seront
mécontentes du fait que il y ait des
faits d'ivers fâcheux au détriment de de
leurs habitants nous allons réussir
l'objectif c'est de réussir le positif
et de pas faire le
négatif un dernier point sur un sujet
que vous avez à juste titre mentionné
comme
fondamental que fait-on au bénéfice des
usagers notamment
contribuables en difficulté ou exclus du
numérique deux choses qui me semble-t-il
caractérisent l'administration fiscale
dans sa relation avec ses usagers et qui
continueront de de la caractériser et
qui la distingue d'un certain nombre de
services publics
le recours aux procédures dématérialisé
pour les opérations grand public n'est
jamais
obligatoire jamais et notamment la
déclaration de revenu peut et pourra
être faite par papier c'est une dizaine
de pourent des foyers fiscaux à peu près
quiours à ce à ce dispositif ça c'est le
premier point le second point nous avons
une organisation de notre politique
d'accueil grand public à nos guichets
qui est très largement différente d'un
grand nombre de servic public compable
nous avons schématiquement de
demi-journées où nous recevons tout le
monde pour le reste du temps nous avons
une capacité de recevoir par rendez-vous
qui est très structuré et je vous donne
un chiffre nous avons reçu l'année
dernière 7 millions de personnes à nos
guichets c'est considérable notamment
dans dans le cadre d'une d'une fiscalité
dans laquelle le prélèvement à la source
d'une part la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation et de la redevance
télévisuelle d'une deuxième part on
réduit le le le volume de questions qui
nous sont adressées et le volume de
demande de délis de paiement qui qui
sont généralement le cœur des demandes
qui sont formées qui sont sont qui nous
sont formulées pardon par les
contribuables nous continuons cette
politique d'ouverture nous la
maintiendrons tant que nous en avons les
moyens et comme je vous disais nous les
avons dans les pour les prochaines
années 7 millions de personnes qui
viennent nous voir chaque année et
j'ajoute à cela
9 millions je crois de d'appel
téléphonique par an qui viennent en plus
c'est pas une administration qui
dématérialise la totalité de ses
relations avec ses usagers c'est normal
et ça va continuer je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Directeur vous pourrez
peut-être poursuivre avec les questions
qui nous qui sont posées par nos
collègues je passe tout de suite la
parole
au utilisateurs si je puis dire je n'ose
dire
client
mais à nos deux présidents qui nous faut
l'amitié de venir donc tout d'abord
Jacques
auberti pour intercommunalité de
France Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur spécial madame la
Présidente bonjour à toutes et à tous
donc Jacques auverti je suis maire d'une
commune de 200800 habitants dans le
laoraguet Sud-Est toulousa en rotgaron
pays cher à
votre président ici présent
euh donc président de la Communauté
d'agglomération du syoval Sud-Est
toulousain 85000 habitants 36 communes
et donc vice-président
d'intercommunalité de France en charge
du numérique justement euh donc je je
vais parler direct comme on dit compte
tenu qui puusit du du temps imparti en
euh rangeant mon propos selon un certain
nombre de de thématiques que vous avez
abordé madame et que je je reprendrai
tout d'abord la la mise en œuvre du du
NRP nouveau réseau de de proximité en
apportant quelques nuances dans dans sa
mise en œuvre je salue d'ailleurs au
passage le fort investissement des des
FIP qui ont dû vivre cette période de
façon très intense les obstacles n'ont
pas manqué vous dire que ils ont sans
doute travailler plus sur l'héritage
qu'effectivement sur une nouvelle
organisation territoriale même si ils
ont eu les moyens on s'en félicite de
pouvoir ça et là positionner de nouveaux
points de de contact euh
particulièrement pour les pour les
collectivité euh en la matière euh il
faut parfaire bien évidemment le le
dispositif il y a encore un peu de temps
mais le temps n'est pas très l euh parce
que les retours que nous avons au niveau
des intercommunalités ce sont bien
évidemment euh ceux des
intercommunalités pour lesquelles le
dispositif n'est est à parfire
naturellement et y compris en matière le
positionnement des des conseillers donc
au aux décideurs locaux euh et
puis le deuxième élément c'est que ce
nouveau positionnement oblige à partir
du moment où il a été annoncé qu'il
devait couvrir l'ensemble des
territoires les collectivités il sont
bien évidemment très attentives et
notamment quand les moyens manquent et
là aussi il faut bien évidemment arriver
à une situation qui convienne à à
l'ensemble des des territoires donc donc
vous dire que il faut réellement remplir
le le contrat la méfiance la défiance
avait été certaine nous avions été
habitués par exemple au travers des des
DDE à des désengagements de de l'État
notamment sur l'instruction et c'est
vrai qu'il faut apaiser en fait ce
sentiment d'abandon des territoires
particulièrement des territoires ruraux
mon collègue en parlera sans doute mieux
que
moi la question des des conseillers
essentiel et d'ailleurs elle crée une
nouvelle dépendance
elle crée une nouvelle
dépendance qui se traduit tout autant
par la nécessité de répondre à toutes
les questions que se posent les
décideurs locaux bien au-delà d'ailleurs
peut-être des missions initiales qui
avaient été fixées ça c'est très
important notamment l'aide à réaliser
les
budgets on a parlé des valeurs
cadastrales point essentiel vous
l'imaginez surtout avec quelques
déception notamment pour l'instant sur
les valeurs locatives des locaux
professionnels et une très forte attente
sur les locaux d'habit
les coefficients de localisation
beaucoup de pédagogie la question aussi
bien évidemment de toutes les recettes à
cet égard nous sommes un petit peu
frustrés sur la question de la CVAE
heureusement que certains EPCI avaient
réaliser des travaux avant même la
bascule vers la TVA pour avoir le
meilleur retour mais les territoires qui
ne l'avaient pas fait comptant peut-être
à un moment sur les conseillers sont
aujourd'hui extrêmement déçu sur la taxe
d'aménagement ou la taxe d'aménagement
majoré là aussi le dispositif est à
parfaire le changement à la fois dans
les flux pouvait être intéressant mais
pour autant le fait de devoir suivre de
façon importante et avec acité notamment
la déclaration d'achèvement des travaux
nécessite d'avoir beaucoup plus de
technicité particulièrement dans les
communes qui n'en ont pas euh donc là
deux très fortes attentes un partenariat
beaucoup plus étroit qui plus est dans
un contexte notamment avec la loi clima
et résilience de
réduction de la croissance des des
valeurs locatives donc la nécessité
aussi de positionner dans une dans une
vision intercommunalité commune le
conseiller comme étant susceptible
d'amener du plus dans un pacte financier
fiscal il faut l'avoir en tête donc des
collaboration qu' va falloir donc
conforter au-delà des conventions qui
ont été signées je dirais un petit peu
pour faire plaisir à la DR FIP et pas
forcément parce que quelque part il
s'agissait d'une réelle réorganisation
territoriale à proprement
parler vous dire que le maire est aussi
l'interlocuteur des propriétaires qui
vivent les déclarations sur la gestion
des biens immobiliers et qu'à cet égard
il y a à certains endroits du territoire
de très forts retards dans le règleement
des des problèmes et le maire est en
première ligne et attend bien évidemment
de de la DRFIP de la DG FIP des progrès
je je crois qu'il faut le dire bien des
territoires aujourd'hui n'ont pas de
réponse à fournir à leurs administrés et
bien des administrés non'ont évidemment
pas de réponse sur C cette gestion là et
c'est souvent l'arbre qui cache la forêt
ce qui est un petit peu
dommage sur sur la
question donc alors malgré tout
confirmation bien évidemment du lien
très fort aujourd'hui entre les les les
CDL et donc les les décideurs locaux
eux-mêmes et donc cela va réellement
dans dans le bon sens mais des des
exigences évidemment qui qui
croissent sur la la la question des des
recettes euh il est vrai qu'il faut
absolument que nous progressions et à
cet égard puisque nous avons parlé de
numérique pourquoi ne pas avoir un
système d'information partagé qui
permettrait aux collectivités d'avoir
exactement les mêmes accès que les
finances publiques en matière de données
pourrions y arriver avec des droits
d'accès bien déterminés et faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une meilleure gestion
des des recettes permettant de
surmultiplier notamment l'investissement
local quand on sait combien les
collectivités territoriales sont attendu
notamment sur la question des
investissements en matière de
transition énergétique et bien
d'autres
sur la sur la la partie des donc du du
Zéro cach c'est-à-dire là aussi pas
vraiment d'égalité territoriale pourquoi
ne pas imaginer d'autres partenaires
locaux qui permettraient le le le
paiement dématérialisés de de de l'impôt
avec des ancrages territoriaux qui
finalement régleraiit aussi bien des
problème en zone rural sans passer
uniquement par par les buralistes ce
peut-être une piste pour simplifier
aussi le le le le paiement un point pour
peut-être ne pas ne pas être trop long
un point complémentaire avec les
collectivités l'accompagnement à la fois
sur la M57 mais aussi sur la sur donc le
CFU donc va dans le bon sens avec une
forme de simplification même si
aujourd'hui peut-être certaines
collectivités se se sent un peu esselé
sur la gestion de la trésorerie pour
autant il faut
effectivement
poursuivre faire en sorte de
d'accompagner aujourd'hui on est encore
dans des phases d'expérimentation mais
on sent effectivement que ce ce cela est
positif évidemment avec de de de
l'amélioration comme je l'ai indiqué je
ne serai pas plus long sur les derniers
points que vous abordez à savoir calquer
en fait l'intervention sur la base des
maisons Fran serv là je demande d'abord
et et d'ailleurs c'est le dernier point
dans V recommandation que l'on évalue la
capacité des maisons France service à
bien couvrir le territoire parce qu'on a
tendance à
évaluer le service rendu par les maisons
France service avec une très forte
approbation des usagers mais pour autant
je ne suis pas sûr aujourd'hui que les
maisons Fran servic rendent partout les
services escomptés il est question
soi-disant de de de 30 minutes de dé
placement pour s'y rendre en milieu
rural on est loin du compte et qui plus
est avec le le numérique je pense qu'il
faut être extrêmement
méfiant à cet égard j'aurais
éventuellement deux suggestions à à
formuler la première c'est que nous
développons aujourd'hui la mise en œuvre
de la feuille de route France Numérique
ensemble il serait peut-être ce serait
peut-être une magnifique opportunité
pour voir dans quelle mesure euh nous
pouvons avoir aussi euh donc un maillage
du du territoire opérationnel dans le
cadre de la des gouvernances locales qui
se mettront en œuvre avec des feuilles
de route remises 12 2024 ce qui
correspond d'ailleurs à votre calendrier
c'est le premier point et puis donc
monsieur le le directeur vous avez parlé
d'intelligence artificielle certes sur
les les valeurs cadastrales mais moi je
vous parlerai d'intelligence
artificielle sur les agents vous savez
que Stanislas Guerini le ancien ministre
des des collectivités a lancé une
expérimentation avec de las générative
ce serait peut-être aussi intéressant
d'essayer d'anticiper sur cette question
et ne pas évidemment tomber dans le
travers du tout numérique en la matière
en favorisant aussi les politiques du du
Halet vert voilà
merci
il a générative on change de monde dans
les débats collectivité local
bon chers
collègueorne
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs d'abord je tiens à vous
remercier de nous avoir invité à cette à
cet échange qui est fondamental pour nos
communes et les échanges qu'on a je
remercie la Cour des comptes de cette
emparer de ce sujet et fondamental je
vais essayer de reprendre madame l'ordre
où vous avez mis un petit peu un certain
nombre de remarques sans reprendre ce
qu'a dit mon mon voisin d'ailleurs sur
le numérique il est bien plus compétent
que moi et il a je trouve des très
bonnes idées
et donc déjà dans le fonctionnement de
la la DG FIP par rapport à à nos
collectivités et sur
euh
le les enfin le le paiement de nosation
je crois que ladessus c'est grosso modo
c'est c'est c'est bien fait et par
contre sur le retard et ça a été signalé
le date tardive sur lesquels on a les
euh les informations sur en particulier
notre
m1259 qui arrive souvent fin
mars quand c'est pas début avril on a
jusqu'au 15 avril normalement pour faire
nos budgets et c'est vrai que pas mal de
collègues on ont du mal à à à anticiper
ce qu'ils auront et c'est compliqué je
vrais dire que je suis aussi au comité
d'ficience locale donc
j'ai j'ai des informations que n'ont pas
beaucoup de mes collègues par rapport à
ça et je SAÉ les idées par rapport à ça
quand on sait le montant de
d'augmentation de la DSR de la DSU et
cetera mais c'est vrai que c'est un
c'est un problème alors je voudrais
parler
de choses qui vont bien une et
quelques-unes qui vont pas bien à mes
yeux mais je vais être vraiment dans le
concret parce que je pense que c'est
c'est les choses concrètes qu'on VO sur
sur mon expérience ou celle de collègues
que j'ai que j'ai rencontré alors ce qui
va bien c'est l'automisation du fond de
compensation de TVA et honnêtement j'ai
eu la bonne surprise jusque-l j'avais au
moins trois éch
avec
le la préfecture
pour pour traiter ce qui était en
novembre on était bien content d'avoir
enfin notre notre d euh cette année en
2023 au mois de février j'ai vu tout
arriver je vous que c'était c'était
c'était bien d'ailleurs au passage et
c'est pas la faute de la DG FIP mais
monsieur le Président je tiens à vous
dire j'étais auditionné hier par un de
vos collègues de la commission des lois
sur un autre tout autre sujet euh et
puis au dernier moment il m'a posé une
question mais pour la le FCTVA comment
ça se passe est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
avancer les choses je lu dis moi le truc
que je trouve le plus scandaleux c'est
le n + 1 N + 2 son idée c'était de tout
ramener en haine comme les
intercomunités B j'ai dis que c'est
peut-être un petit peu utopique par
contre travailler là-dessus je je le
place ça s'appelle un cavalier je sais
pas voilà bon je reviens àre chose des
choses sur lesquelles c'est c'est très
très peu clair je parle de la commission
communale des impôts directs dire bon ça
fait pas mal de temps que je suis maire
il y a une seule fois où une personne DG
FIP qui est venu nous expliquer quand on
reçoit ses papiers complètement euh
abscond et bon c l'année du covid j'ai
rien vu n arriver bon l'année d'après je
me suis tiens c'est bizarre et après je
me suis aperçu qu'on nous l'envoyait euh
directement euh en fichier sans nous
avoir trop prévenu et j'avoue qu'il y a
eu une année ou deux où c'est passé
complètement inaperçu dans ma commune et
on a tellement de choses à faire que
d'un coup on s'y tient c'est bizarre bon
ceci étant les fichiers sont très très
peu clairs honnêtement et puis euh les
quelques fois on a voulu changer des
choses on a fait comprendre qu'on qu'on
avait rien compris et que donc on
changeait rien du tout donc je me
demande si euh une fois par mandat
peut-être on pourrait pas dire que il y
a un agent de la DG FIP qui vient qui
vient nous expliquer vraiment comment
c'est comment ça fonctionne qu'est-ce
que c'est quels sont nos droits et
peut-être qu'on regarde ensemble au
niveau cadastral s'il y a des choses qui
qui vont bien ou qui vont moins bien
et autre chose sur
l'information en août
2023 pas mal de mes collègues et
moi-même qui était comme l'a fait
comprendre la ministre madame for à
l'époque que des vill petit canard que
nous avions augmenté notre tau de taxes
d'habitation en 2018 ou 2019 et d'un
coup on nous a réclamé en 2023 au mois
d'O 2023 c'est peut-être arrivé moi
j'étais en vacances donc pe arrivé fin
juillet hein on nous a réclamé de de
l'argent qui était pas du tout prévu
dans nos comptes on l'a pas su avant bon
alors il paraît que ça avait été voté en
2020 je veux bien le croire ceci étant
on aurait pu au moment de faire nos
budgets nous prévenir voyez attention on
va vous réclamer le le laaristourne
qu'on a donné au particulierers pour
très brièvement quand en 2020
euh quand on a augmenté ce sa taxe
habitation en 2020 il y avait encore de
la taxehabitation et les gens devaient
payer le relicat qui était en plus mais
comme on avait promis qu'il y aurait
plus de de taxes d'habitation c'était
difficile de dire aux gens bah vous avez
un petit vous avez 35 € à payer ou 25 €
à payer donc on l'a pas fait on a fait
payer aux communes en 2023 et ça on nous
l' réclamé sans que bon peut-être les
gens très avertis l'été moi je c'est
arrivé mais la plupart de mes collègues
sont arrivés furieux en me disant mais
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette affaire là
j'étais au départ bien incapable de leur
dire sur la taxe d'aménagement tu en a
parlé c'est vrai que j'ai discuté
avec par rapport à tax d'aménagement le
le changement de méthode qui après tout
change aller dans le bon sens puisque
c'est la rationalité des rationalisation
des choses par contre le fait que ce
soit après le
le la fin de l'achèvement des travaux ça
pose quand même inquiétude je suis
président d'un pas président pardon
excuse-moi je suis trésorier d'un d'un
Cau on vit à 94 % sur la taxe
d'aménagement je voudrais dire que on a
des inquiétudes alors euh et de quoi bon
j'en ai parlé à à Guillaume Robert que
vous devez connaître puisque je je
rencontre d'ailleurs je dois le
rencontrer demain puisque la DG FIP nous
invite les assant d'élus à à discuter il
m'a dit euh fait comprendre que moi
j'avais fait des petits calculs tout
bêtes hein si j'ai regardé combien de
temps il y avait entre les le le dépôt
des euh enfin l'acceptation de permis de
construire les donc grosso modo j'avais
17 mois dans ma commune et j'ai regardé
le délai et cetera je vous passe ce
détail donc normalement il manquait 6
mois on m'a assuré que mes calculs
étaient faux parce que ça allait aller
plus vite et ceci étant on aurait besoin
un peu j'en aurais peut-être demain on
aurait besoin d'un peu plus de précision
par rapport à ça et en particulier euh
alors nos communes c'est pas une somme
énorme mais c'est quand même une somme
importante pour un Cau par contre c'est
c'est fondamental puisqu'on vit
là-dessus et 6 mois de trésorerie c'est
si c'est vraiment 6 mois ça fait bon on
peut espérer que ça aille un peu plus
vite et je fais quand même confiance à
DG FIP
là-dessus voilà pour quelques points
qui qui me semble délicat et qui font
que je dirais que l'ADN de laadg FIP
c'est naturellement pas la pédagogie ça
c'est vrai je peux le comprendre ceci
étant Robert là
derrière
mais euh je crois qu'il y a un gros
effort pour mes collègues il y en a
beaucoup comme B au dernier CFL on avait
euh
euh il y a une de nos collègues qui a
dit tout d'un coup quand on reçoit les
les dotations ben qu'est-ce qu'on
regarde on regarde au bout on comprend
rien ce qui se passe avant donc je sais
bien que c'est un peu compliqué on va
reparler au CFL du la semaine prochaine
je pense de tout ça mais c'est vrai que
mais tout n'est pas de la faute d' DGFiP
il y a des tas de règles qui sont
compliquées qui ne sont pas là il ne
fait que les appliquer mais je dis qu'il
a il y a quand même des des difficultés
par rapport à ça et grosso modo il nous
faudrait une information beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus claire par
rapport à ça et peut-être dans des
termes très très simples pour pour
beaucoup de mes collègues qui sont
perdus dans dans ce schéma de
différentes choses et quand on est ma de
particulier de petites communes mais on
est amené à avir à trancher sur un
nombre tellement varié de domaines que
on n pas le temps de passer trop de
temps à chacun malheureusement al
deuxième point je voulais parler de bon
la réfaction des des trésoreries bon
là-dessus on va pas revenir en arrière
je le sais bien mais c'est vrai qu'un
petit exemple quand j'ai commencé comme
maire on avait une trésorerie pour CQ
commune no trésorier venaent à notre
commission des finances on avait des
échanges permanents c'est vrai que c'est
comme ça que j'ai appris à à manier les
finances de ma commune ça c'est d'un
passé lointain c'était au siècle dernier
parce que tuit Luère en 95 mais voilà
maintenant le enfin le même trésorier à
25 ou 30 communes quelques syndicats une
grosse de communes et autant dire que on
a pas alors j'ai pas le 06 de ma
conseillère des locaux mais je son 07
donc ça doit vous rassurer quand même
hein je je voudrais dire que euh alors
ça doit dépendre des personnes é
remarquable pour moi cétait impéccable
elle m'a dépanné deux fois où j'avais
des difficultés la seule chose c'est que
j'ai eu du temps à savoir qu'elle
existaitin je pense que ça aurait été
bien qu'elle aille se présenter dans
toutes les communes dont elle la
responsabilité qu'elle rencontre le
maire et le ou la secrétaire générale ça
aurait été pas mal je un petit je pas
une critique que je lui fait mais qu'
qu'on ait un petit message queil aille
se présenter dans les communes et qui
donne vraiment tout ce qu' qu' peuvent
faire
et donc cette éloignance pour les
particuliers c'est aussi un peu
compliqué je veux dire on
a 60 80 % de nos particuliers qui Mani
bien le numérique ont pas de problème si
juste par le recensement c'est déjà 60 %
qu' répondu donc il y a 40 % mais c'est
pas forcément 40 % qui sont il sont qui
qui connaissent pas mais il en a 10 15 %
qui ont des grosses difficultés qui on
encore la déclaration papier et j'ai une
dame de 90 ans qui est venue voir parce
queelle était complètement paniquée
parce qu'il fallait déclarer sa maison
avant le 30 juin on pas réussi parce
qu'on avait pas son numéro de
télédéclarant qui était sur sa fiche
papier qu'elle avait envoyé pour ses
impôts enfin il faut vraiment là qu' a
des des moyens que ces personnes âgées
soient soient mieux aidé alors
évidemment alors jeevenenir sur ce que
tu as dit sur les maisons France serv
euh jeessis pas répéter mais là-dessus
je
en français les choses c'est mieux de se
répéter que de ce contredire
pardon non mais je veux dire que le le
lien alors je sais pas quel est le
cahier de charge qui a été donné au
maison France service il y en a beaucoup
qui sont pas allés voir les communes non
plus je veux dire que le le début c'est
le premier kilomètre le premier mtre
nous dit le président des mer Michel
Fournier c'est celui-là qui est qui est
important et c'est là qu'on vient dans
dans les mairies il faut vraiment que on
les encourage à faire alors c'est pas la
DG FIP mais je je parle de tout il
encouragé à à faire plus de relations
euh pour que on sache qu'on puisse
mettre dans nos sur nos panneaux divers
et variés que nous les commune on puisse
indiquer qu'il y a une permanence d'ADG
FIP à tel endroit et cetera et et puis
on a parlé de formation des des
secrétaires de mairie non c'est vrai que
très
souvent sont un peu perdus dans toutes
ces choseslà il ou ell sont toujours un
peu perdu dans dans toutes ces chosesl
et donc il y a il y a du du travail à
faire mais encore des documents très
très simples où les choses sonit
expliquées alors tout n'est pas expliqué
on renvoie en en plus complexe mais
quand le m1259 à part quelques maniaques
comme moi qui lisons tous les détails il
y a beaucoup de gens ben ils comprennent
pas dès la deuxième page qui se passe il
regarde juste la différence donc
là-dessus il y a vraiment un gros effort
et je pense dans beaucoup communes
rurales où il a 200 300 habitants
honnêtement même 1000 habitants on a il
y en a beaucoup qui ont énormément du
mal à suiv tout ça ça et à à gérer le
leur budget voilà très brièvement les
mes mes réflexions
là-dessus merci monsieur le Président
[Musique]
euh puisque vous êtes rentré et c'est ce
qu'on vous demandz à tous les deux de
rentrer dans les dans les détails précis
certains qui sont
directement de la compétence de la DG
FIP d'autres au marge on va dire mais
c'est bien c'est bien normal puisque
vous êtes vous êtes sur ce terrain je
voulais vous qu'avec le rapporteur
général nous vous envoyons ce matin à
tous les collègues sénateurs la liste
des communes concernées par France
revitalisation ruralité voilà FRR donc
vous aurez tout ceci dans vos boîtes ma
je le dis parce que comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure le maire il n'ouvre pas toujours
les boîtes mail donc regardez-le vous
l'avez dans votre boîte mail aujourd'hui
bien ceci étant
dit je voudrais vous indiquer je vais
vous don don la parole mes chers
collègues pour une série de questions
d'abord au rapporteur général bien
entendu je voudrais indiquer à nos
invités que ils auront un deuxè tour de
réponse par rapport aux questions qui
sont posées par nos collègues il faudra
y répondre de manière très succinte en
prenant les éléments ou les questions
qui vous paraissent de votre compétence
quant à à l'apport de de répondre donc
nous le ferons dans le sens inverse et
madame la Présidente conclura donc nos
travaux monsieur le rapporteur
général oui merci monsieur le Président
d'abord merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Général
effectivement j'ai bien entendu par
intérim je veis également évidemment
remercier les
élus moi je suis assez partagé mais je
dirais plutôt positivement puisque j'ai
souvent eu l'occasion dans les débats
sur le sujet de la
réorganisation de la Direction générale
des finances publiques et des
trésoreries des plutôt euh enclin à
faire confiance et en soutien euh à
cette démarche qui me paraissait viser
une adaptation modernisation
déploiement logiquement pour être plus
efficace mieux réparti j'ai le sentiment
ça a été dit hein le le bilan
globalement positif que c'est plutôt ce
qui se passe et c'est je le dis aussi
avec toute la prudence cert mais euh
c'est tellement rare d'avoir depuis
plusieurs années une démarche qui est
annoncée qui est
concertée peut-être pas toujours
suffisamment enfin mise en œuvre et qui
globalement semble à peu près atteindre
sa cble euh voilà je je le dis euh comme
ça c'est les ceux qui en sont les
auteurs mais chacun y ayant pris sa part
parce que quand il la concertation
chacun y prend sa part et c'est pas fini
voilà je pense que c'est une bonne chose
et quand je dis c'est pas fini je suis
effectivement ass assez sensible au
sujet des 30 minutes alors 30 minutes je
dira en voiture selon l'endroit où vous
êtes c'est pas forcément 30 minutes on
va quand même pas se raconter l'histoire
c'est exactement comme les distributeurs
aomatiques de billets et de ce côté-là
autant je pense qu'il faut adapter nos
comment dirais-je nos réflexions les
projets les évolutions et y mettre de
l'intelligence artificielle mais il y a
il y a encore très peu de temps parler
beaucoup d'intelligence collective et
j'y suis plus attaché c'est-à-dire qu'il
faut encore des temps de rencontres avec
les femmes et les hommes pour comprendre
lever des doutes voilà en général une
réclamation bien traitée vous fait une
fédéisation pour 10 ans c'est un vieux
principe du commerce mais je crois que
ça vaut
également moi je voulais revenir
peut-être sur quelques questions donc
dans le rapport de la Cour vous nous
dites qu' y a quasiment 3000 communes
qui
aujourd'hui
bénéficie des services
réorganisés et notamment vous préviez
néanmoins que alors qu'on est déjà
au-dessus de l'objectif vous pensez
qu'il faudrait encore certains endroits
conforter la présence notamment me
semble-t-il dans les espaces France
service j'aurais je voulais un peu plus
loin de quelle manière c'estàd est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est un présent
dans plus de communes ou c'est la
question des agents qui sont là à titre
temporaire une des bout de demi-journée
ou parfois sur un temps plus concentré
parce que ça peut être lié à des besoins
de service estivaux j'allais dire dans
dans certains territoires donc quel est
comment
dirais-je l'appréciation que vous porter
deuxè élément sur le je dirais le lien
entre usager commune est-ce que vous
avez pu apprécier alors soit par le le
sondage soit est-ce qu'il y a l'idée
d'avoir un un conduit ou peut-être
d'avoir bientôt un questionnaire
d'appréciation sur le niveau de service
le niveau de satisfaction ce qui est
puis essayer d'évaluer le ressenti et
puis la la réalité des choses parce que
parfois il y a aussi dans un même
territoire une dissonance pour sortir
mais je suis pas le seul on est la
moitié d'entre nous on sort de campagne
électorale en fait on sent très bien
c'est malheureusement parfois d'abord le
le fait d'une personne avec laquelle le
contact passe très bien et ça roule et
quand il passe mal c'est pas que ça
déroule c'est que ça voilà ça
bloque trème élément peut-être sur la
question du coût du service sur les le
sujet des des des prestations
d'encaissement pour toutes les créances
publiques avec le réseau des buralistes
dont moi je pense que c'est une bonne
idée puisque là où on avait une présence
famélique on a une amplitude horaire
plus importante finalement on
consolide la qualité la présence du
service au quotidien parce que le
buraliste je dirais il a pas le choix
c'est son métier de rendre le service
public et privé mais il y a un coût de
service qui est quand même élevé hein
puisque chaque paiement est facturé à
l'état entre 4 et 5 € quel que soit le
le coût de l'encaissement ce qui fait 10
à 12 millions d'euros alors je je sais
hein on parle l'unité de valeur est
plutôt le milliard mais je comme je sais
que les petites
économies font les les grandes ensuite
je voulais recevoir peut-être votre
appréciation surtout euh lorsque l'on si
on se projette dans dans l'évolution
à mon avis qui ira moins vite que ce que
d'cin pense du Zéro cash je dis ça parce
qu'on est encore loin de ce qu'on avait
vu il y a 5 ans en Suède où on était à
13 % ce qui semblait être le le seuil
minimal minimal
voilà merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je vais donc donner la parole à
nos collègues en commençant par Hervé
Moret puis Antoine
Lefèvre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur général madame la
Présidente quelques quelques mots par
rapport à ce que ce qui a été dit ce ce
matin moi j'ai entendu certains parler
de de bilan globalement positif j'avoue
que c'est pas du tout le ressenti que
j'ai sur le sur le terrain et et je
préfère le dire tout de suite je crois
qu'au contraire la réorganisation des
trésoreries ça a été dit par la Cour
d'ailleurs est vécu comme un recul de
plus des services publics en en milieu
en milieu rural moi dans mon département
on a quand même fermé 11 trésoreries et
c'est dans un département rural c'est
évidemment pas sans conséquence ça pose
un certain nombre de problèmes il y a le
problème de la localisation qui est
enfin de l'éloignement plutôt qui est
qui est important ça a été dit par le
représentant des des mères ruraux ça ça
conduit aussi à ce que les les les les
les agents des trésoreries soient moins
disponibles pour participer à des
réunions ça conduit à à des obligations
de de transport qui sont pas
négligeables par que souvent au milieu
rural on aime encore aller à la
trésorerie on travaille pas forcément de
de manière dématérialisée et puis
surtout moi j'observe je sais pas c'est
le fait du hasard mais un nombre de
dysfonctionnement qui ne me remontait
pas jusqu'à présent c'est-à-dire des
délais de paiement des entreprises qui
sont très longs avec parfois des des
situations qui pose problème aux
entreprises moi j'ai dû ce que j'avais
jamais fait jusque-l intervenir auprès
des services de la trésorerie pour que
des entreprises soient payées parce que
il y avait vraiment un risque sur
l'existence même de ces entreprises il y
a des demandes de plus en plus ubues qui
sont faites au maire alors parfois ils
ont le sentiment que c'est pour que les
dossiers ne soient pas traités on leur
demande des pièces supplémentaires
histoire de de mettre tout ça de de de
de côté donc voilà je crois que je veux
pas être trop long mais c'est c'est
vraiment ce que ce qu'on observe sur le
terrain alors le le rapporteur spécial
disait qu'on pouvait pas avoir une
trésorerie par interco c'est vrai mais
il y a parfois des choses qui
surprennent quand on voit quelqu'un dans
mon département une très grosse interco
dont la ville centre est une des
principales villes du département qui
n'a pas du tout de trésorerie alors que
dans la alors qu'à côté c'est une plus
petite ville qui elle à la trésorerie
qui couvre également cette grande
interco il y a quand même des des choses
qui peuvent qui peuvent paraître
bizarres pour ne pas dire un peu
copinage politique je suis dans un
département où c'est vrai que ça se
pratique un tout petit peu mais je je
ferme très vite la
parenthèse
là-dessus à cela s'ajoute aussi et c'est
sans doute lié aussi à ces
réorganisations que les élus se
plaignent quand même d'avoir avoir de
plus en plus de difficultés quant au
recouvrement de leurs créances et quant
à l'information même de la situation de
ces créances je vais prendre un exemple
qui m'a été remonté par plusieurs Maes
qui n'arrive même pas à savoir si le
logement communal qui est loué est payé
ou pas c'estàd si le locataire est à
jour ou pas alors qu'avant en plus avec
la suppression des régies on a amené le
chèque à la mairie le maire il suivait
ça si c'était pas payé il pouvait aller
voir le locataire aujourd'hui non
seulement il a plus ça mais il sait même
pas si le locataire est à jour ou pas
donc vraiment même sur des choses très
simples
ça pose ça pose quand même pas mal de de
de problèmes tout ça et puis j'en
terminerai bon alors je trouve que les
le constat de la de la Cour est tout à
fait pertinent les recommandations je
les trouve un tout petit peu décevant de
mon point de vue et puisqu'on a la
chance d'avoir un représentant de de la
DG FIB j'aimerais lui poser une question
qui est un tout petit peu en marge du
sujet j'en conviens mais quand même
comment se fait-il que les services de
de la DG FIP et aussi mal aluer les
communes pouvant bénéficier du filet de
sécurité ça c'est quand même un truc
incroyable je vais à nouveau prendre les
chiffres de mon département dans mon
département 15 152 communes ont dû
reverser la compte touché au titre du
filet de sécurité quand seulement 27 à
compte ont été confirmés comment c'est
possible et je vous laisse imaginer tout
le monde se rendra compte parmi mes
collègues le la difficulté que ça que ça
cause à une commune qui a touché qui a
encaissé et à qui on dit bah finalement
poisson d'avril vous aurez rien du tout
voilà mon le Président vous a l' de
douter de mes propos mais je les
confirme ah pas du tout vous êes vous
aviez une moue que je vous connais mais
c'est ou c'est ça c'était pour vous dire
j'allis vous dire vécu terrain normand
voilà j'en ai fini j'allais vous dire
cher collègue que vous me paraissiez pas
à côté du sujet voilà donc c'est un
élément mais dans le sujet alors Antoine
Lefèvre puis St sa oui merci monsieur le
Président merci à notre rapporteur
spécial et aux différents intervenants
alors tout d'abord à la suite de notre
collègue je partage également le
ressenti que le le bilan n'est pas
globalement positif en ce qui concerne
mon département de de l'INE où la
réforme a été parfois difficile à à
mettre en œuvre moi j'ai j'ai deux
questions tout d'abord justement ce
nouveau réseau de
proximité a-t-il permis de réduire le
nombre de de comp eux fiscal ou
budgétaire dans les avec les
collectivités c'était aussi un des un
des objectifs annoncés dans dans cette
réforme et puis le deuxième aspect c'est
concernant la la ressource humaine et et
justement la la territorialisation des
des services fiscaux est-ce que la DG
FIP bénéficie suffisamment de
d'effectifs pour irriguer l'ensemble de
territoires et en particulier dans les
territoires ruraux est-ce que les postes
sont arrivent à être pourvus assez
facilement merci merci Antoine Stéphane
sotarel puis Florence batrice contta
oui merci euh monsieur le Président
Madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
eu une ou deux remarques et et et une
question euh effectivement le le le
bilan il est sans doute un peu plus
contrasté que ce qu'on a entendu selon
les les les territoires euh en
particulier sur des difficultés en tout
cas sur rencontrées sur sur mon
territoire dans le Cantal euh sur euh
les conditions des services de gestion
comptable et donc de paiement avec des
retards considérables mettant même en
difficulté l'économie et les entreprises
sur le sur le territoire alors qui
peuvent relever de de questions assez
ponctuelles de de personnes mais mais
mais qui perdurent malgré tout assez
assez longuement euh je partage
pleinement la la première recommandation
de de la cour hein parce
qu'effectivement cette articulation
entre les conseillers les services de
gestion comptable pose encore un certain
nombre de de difficultés
y compris sur des contradictions
notamment sur des questions d'imputation
ou de ou d'affectation de de de dépenses
donc c'est assez curieux et ça met quand
même en difficulté les les les communes
que ce soit les les élus ou ou ou le
secrétariat de de commune et et ces
phénomènes là sont pas rares ils sont
assez répandus malheureusement
euh une question particulière
effectivement centrée sur la question le
sujet de des dépôts
des régies des services publics avec
l'éloignement qu'on peut constater et
puis un tiers des communes qui ne sont
pas satisfaites du partenariat noué avec
la Banque Postale donc j'aimerais avoir
si possible des explications sur ce sur
ce point-là et notamment sur ce que la
DG FIP pe peut
aujourd'hui répondre sur sur C ces bons
d'urgence en espèce pour les administrer
les plus fragiles agile qui s'inquiète
de la stratégie du Zéro cche qu'a
soulevé le rapporteur général et et et
qui semble aujourd'hui effectivement un
peu loin des r des réalité notamment en
ruralité
merci merci Stéphane Florence Patrice
conta puis Bernard
delcro merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente je veux remercier
tous les intervenants bien entendu
souligner la qualité du rapport sur la
réforme des implantations de la gfip
dans le cadre du projet nouveau réseau
de proximité projet qui porte pas
forcément qui qui peut être mal nommé en
tout cas c'est perçu comme cela par les
collectivités parce que je crois que les
collègues l'ont indiqué le le
regroupement des trésoreries s traduit
pour les élus par un éloignement
d'ailleurs le le rapport en fait état la
cartographie des services de la DG FIP
ne semble pas pertinent à 67 % des
communes rurales et un autre élément moi
qui qui m'interpelle c'est que
globalement toujours dans les communes
rurales les secrétaires de mairie ne se
sentent pas suffisamment formés par la
DG FIB c'est 57 %
et moi le ressenti que j'ai dans mon
département de lin c'est que globalement
il y a un sous-dimensionnement dans les
services de gestion comptable qui est
vraiment ressenti et ce
sous-dimensionnement a un impact
évidemment sur le travail des des
secrétaires de mairie c'est manque des
ctif ont un impact avec des difficultés
à obtenir des réponses rapidement et en
même temps des demandes de plus en plus
forte de la DG FIP avec une injonction
souvent de traité rapidement donc cela
entraîne une forme de difficulté dans le
travail de nos secrétaires de mairie je
voulais vraiment l'indiquer et puis cela
se traduit je pense que vraiment ça
bienent du manque d'effectif
d'ailleurs un tableau indique que la
baisse des effectifs dans les
trésoreries dans les pies a été de 24 %
et voilà je pense qu'on est vraiment
arrivé à la limite de l'exercice parce
que moi aussi dans mon département j'ai
des exemples de euh dé laai de paiement
très longs
euh aux entreprises et certaines
entreprises indiquent au mairies qu'ell
euh qu'à ces conditions elles auront du
mal à continuer à à travailler avec les
mairies donc vraiment cette question des
effectif et pour moi essentiel et
dégrade vraiment la qualité du service
auprès des collectivités je vous
remercie merci Florent c'est Bernard
delco puis Jean-Marie mon oui merci
monsieur le Président merci à la Cour
des comptes à notre rapporteur spécial
et et tous no tous nos intervenants une
ou deux remarques et et une question
mais mes remarques vont rejoindre ce qui
a été dit précédemment je je pense
que globalement la réforme des
trésoreries alors côté élus locaux puis
après je reviendrai au aux usagers côté
élus locaux le référme trésorie a
globalement était plutôt bien perçu mais
il faut dire qu'on avait tellement
dépouillé les trés trésoreries de
proximité de leur personnel de leurs
compétences de leurs services que les
trésoreries notamment en milieu rural
n'arrivaient plus à
assurer avoir les compétences
nécessaires pour pour accompagner les
élus et donc du coup globalement cette
réforme a été plutôt bien perçu par par
les élus notamment avec la la nomination
des conseillers au au au aux décideurs
locaux mais il y a quand même des
disparités très importantes suivant les
territoires et moi je le vois chez moi
je rejoins ce qu'a dit mon collègue
Stéphan SAREL à l'INT à l'intérieur même
d'un d'un même euh d' d'un même
département parce que comme le disait le
rapporteur général souvent ça repose sur
une ou deux personnes et en fonction des
personnes c'est toujours les gens qui
font les choses en fonction des
personnes où les choses se passent bien
et les élus sont plutôt satisfaits parce
qu'on leur apporte l'accompagnement et
les compétences nécessaires où ça n'est
pas le cas euh et du coup euh et du coup
je pense que là euh il faudrait euh
améliorer la réactivité par rapport euh
au secteur où ça se passe pas très bien
parce qu'on s'aperçoit euh ça vaut à la
fois pour le service comptable et je
rejoins ce qui a été dit sur les les
retards qui sont assez enfin
inacceptable que sur euh que sur la
question de l'accompagnement des des des
élus ou des secrétaires de mairie je
pense que là où ça se passe bien ben
c'est parfait il faut continuer mais là
où il y a des difficultés il faut
arriver à résoudre rapidement euh les
questions peut-être ça passe par des
changements de personne par des ou par
compléter les compléter les les services
en tous les cas ça n'est pas pensable
que pendant des mois des mois des mois
une année on passe à la 2uxè année on
rencontre toujours les mêmes difficultés
donc je pense qu'il faut améliorer la
capacité à réagir pour régler les
problèmes là où il y en a et encore une
fois c'est c'est c'est des questions
souvent de de de personne et puis ma ma
ma question porte alors c'est plus du
côté des des usagers mais effectivement
vous l'avez rappelé on a multiplié en
fait on a augmenté le nombre de de de de
points de points à travers le le réseau
Fran service le nombre de points où la
DGFiP est présente mais là aussi on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a une inégalité assez
forte en fonction des territoires dans
les départements et donc moi du coup
j'ai une question sur lorsque la DG FIP
est présente elle est partenaire
d'ailleurs la DG FIP des des Fran
services est-ce qu'il y a quand même un
cadre national pour fixer quelques des
charge en quelque sorte quelques
conditions de présence présence
ponctuelle présence régulière présence
renforcé à certains moments de l'année
présence physique
présence en visio prise de rendez-vous
possible ou pas il me semble qu'il y a
des disparités très grandes suivant les
départements donc est-ce que niveau
départemental et des défis pront toute
l'attitude pour pour gérer ça à leur
façon ou est-ce qu'il y a un cadre
national en tous les cas s'il y a des
pas je pense ça serait intéressant de le
créer pour qu'il y ait un vrai service
qui soit apporté dans ces maisons France
service qui effectivement peuvent
apporter un service de de proximité à
aux usagers voilà je vous remercie merci
Bernard Jean-Marie mizon puis Christian
Billac merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais à mon tour remercier l'ensemble
des intervenants et souligner le rapport
du le la qualité du rapport de la Cour
des comptes voyez-vous si jusqu quici je
n'avais pas compris la différence qu'il
y a entre le réel et le ressenti ce
matin je la mesure mieux comme certains
de mes collègues qui m'ont précédé la
différence est forte entre ce que vivent
les élus locaux et ce que montre ce
rapport j'en me réjouis peut-être la
réalité s'est-elle trompée mais hélas
hélas je crains que non ce qu'ils
attendent les élus locaux c'est souvent
des renseignements des informations
contextualisées or le
regroupement la suppression des
trésoreries locales n'a pas bénéficié à
cette qualité de
d'information la structure budgétaire
d'une commune dépend aussi de l'avenir
de cette commune elle peut intégrer des
éléments de progression parce qu'elle a
connaissance de tels ou tels aspect qui
pourront changer la structure budgétaire
qui est la sienne mais ça ça n'est plus
permis je ne connais pas de d'élus qui
ont le 06 ou le 07 du conseiller euh des
décideurs locaux peut-être il y en
a-t-il mais moi je sans doute il y en
a-t-il mais je peux vous dire que je
suis toujours président de l'association
des mèes ruraux de mon département la
Mzelle et je peux vous dire qu'à chaque
assemblée générale le DD FIP est sur le
grille il est plus que chauté mais à
chaque assemblée générale donc j'étais
je suis tombé de haut Monsieur le
Directeur Général par intérim lorsque
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
l'administration des finances publiques
était l'administration préférée des
Français
vous mais j'ai compris la différence
entre le réel et le ressenti je je doute
un peu qu'il en soit ainsi mais
mais peut-être aussi certains agents
mais ça ce n'est pas de votre fête font
du zel vous savez quand pour des
paiements mineurs on demande
systématiquement la production d'
contrat quand vous achetez des fleurs
pour pour la doyenne du village vous
n'avez pas de contrat vous avez une
facture quand on vous demande
systématiquement un contrat vous avez le
droit d'être agacé c'est un peu ce qui
se passe dans certaines dans certaines
trésoreries et et aussi certaines des
trésoreries ont du mal à conserver le
personnel parce qu' elles sentent
éloigné des centres urbains et c'est
difficile d'y fixer je comprends votre
souci d'y fixer la la les ressources
humaines parce qu'il y a un tover très
fort ma ma question est comme celle des
intervenants précédents enfin rejoint C
c'est celle du du du est-ce que ce
nouveau réseau de proximité a oui ou non
permis de réduire les délais de paiement
parce que je constate que dans certains
territoires il y a encore dans mon
département des des délis encore trop
importants mais peut-être est-ce un
département puisqu'il est au nombre de
ceux souvent frontaliers d'ailleurs qui
ont perdu le nombre de services qui
étaient le leure fait partie de ceux qui
qui ont qui qui sonent un peu négligés
enfin qui ont pas été suffisamment bien
traités par l'administration préférée
des
Français bon merci Jean-Marie donc le
rendez-vous à Moselle va s'organiser
alors Christian bac puis Didier
rambau ah oui
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur messieur chers
collègues je vais être bref parce que
mes collègues ont beaucoup dit sur le
ressenti mais je crois que quelque part
aussi là il faut tenir compte de la
remarque de notre rapporteur général
c'est souvent une question de personne
si on a la bonne personne les M sont
contents ceux qui ont hérité d'une
personne moins compétente moins
disponible moins ouverte ils sont moins
content voilà c'est très partagé selon
les territoires et les territoires c'est
à surgf les territoires sur lequel vous
dit ça donc c'est c'est quelque chose de
très très contrasté bon je vais être
rapide un souvenir de remarques et une
question le souvenir on parlait de
cadastre moi j'ai connu l'époque tous
les ans il y avait un agent du cadastre
qui venait et qui en 1 heure 1 heure et
dem réglait tous les problèmes de litige
sur le la commune alors moi je sais bien
qu'avec le bilan carbone il faut pas se
déplacer mais peut-être qu'avec la
voiture électrique on pourrait euh
envoyer les gens sur le terrain ce qui
évite des échanges de courriers qui n'en
finissent pas des incompréhensions et de
mécontentements les deux remarques
d'abord
sur la fameuse révision des valeurs
locatives je réitère ce que j'ai déjà
dit on a fait uneinagas pour la révision
des locaux
professionnels je pense qu'on va faire à
nouveau nouveau une usine à gas pour la
révision des valeurs locatives des
taxeshabitation attention c'est pas la
même chose les locaux professionnel bon
d'abord c'est les entreprises qui les
paient c'est pas tout à fait pareil que
quand le PAI avvec l'argent qu'on a à la
poche et puis il y en a beaucoup plus
donc moi je réitère ma proposition
laissons les maires et les commissions
communales des impôts fixer les valeurs
locatives valeurs locative ça veut dire
le prix auquel le bien est
loué et arrêtons avec des secteurs des
sous-secteurs des coefficients des trucs
des machins et à la fin le maire
découvre que ce chiffre sorti de vos
ordinateurs très performant et
certainement ne correspond à rien et
surtout pas à la volonté de la
commission communale des impô donc j'ai
entendu le président de la République et
le Premier ministre parler de
simplification simplifion on fixe la
valeur locative c'est-à-dire le montant
auquel le bien est loué c'est quand même
simple c'est c'est de la grand-mère la
deuxième remarque c'est la taxe
d'urbanisme j'avais alerté non pas sur
le transfert de l'administration de DDTM
à l'administration des gfip soit soit
mais sur le fait qu'on l'encaisse à la
fin j'avais dit que ça entraîne des
ruptures de trésorerie pour les
collectivité et j'avais dit que ça
entraînerait des sitations dramatiques
pour les particuliers qui souvent je
crois que tous ont voit ça dans nos
communes lorsqu'ils construisent le
pavillon ils ont plus d'argent pour
faire la peinture du séjour et ne
parlons pas des murs de clôture et là on
va leur dire vous aviez oublié mais a la
taxe d'habitation à payer moi j'avais
proposé par amendement que ce soit
encaissé au début des travaux quand ils
viennent d'encaisser l'emprunt ils
étaient débarrassés là on va avir des
situation dramatique et les
collectivités parce que j'avais dit dans
mon intervention que en 35 ans de mandat
j'avais reçu deux achèvements de travaux
personne ne les dépose les achèvements
de travaux et il faut l'achèvement des
travaux pour qu'on la TA alors ma
question c'est ça où on en est sur cette
ta très sincèrement Monsieur le
Directeur merci Christian alors on va
conclure plus rapidement Didier rambau
puis Olivier Pacot merci monsieur le
Président donc aussi une question au
directeur de de la DG FIP mais plutôt
sous l'angle de la la prospective nous
sommes en train de
vivre une révolution la sûrement la la
plus radicale depuis celle de de
Gutemberg qui est celle de
l'intelligence
artificielle et qui et d'ailleurs qui va
impacter toutes nos politiques publiques
et qui d'ailleurs pour la première fois
va aussi concerner plutôt de ce qu'on
appelle les col blanc alors j'ai envie
de dire comment la de vous poser la
question comment au niveau de la DG FIP
on a on anticipe cette cette révolution
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce que
finalement ça va pas être un formidable
à tout et ça va pas être la réponse à à
tous les questionnements que qu'on vient
d'avoir posés par les par les collègues
ou est-ce que faut le voir comme une
crainte merci merci Didier Olivier PAC
merci président alors je vais essayer
d'être bref comme tu m'y engages comme
vous m'y engagez monsieur président en
m'excusant c'est le problème c'est le
problème des derniers donc effec
d'ailleurs ce qu'on dit mes collègues
Moret satarel Mison delcro concernant la
relativité de la satisfaction je le
partage totalement parce que dans mon
département j'ai pas beaucoup de maires
qui sont satisfaits de la réorganisation
et de la qualité du service rendu comme
l'a dit l' miibiac effectivement tout
dépend des hommes ou des femmes mais
tout dépend aussi des cadres qu'on leur
donne et comme l'a dit Laam Mison au
sujet de l'exemple précis de la facture
de fleurs il y a certains trésoriers qui
ont l'art d'avoir un Zil mal placé et la
question c'est de savoir est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas que il y ait des consignes
au niveau des DDFIP vis-à-vis des
trésoriers voir des conseillers au
décideurs locaux pour plus de souplesse
parce que quand moi je vois mon DD FIP
lui me dit qu'il demande de la souplesse
et les trésoriers disent l'inverse bon
ma question c'est une question qui est
peut-être un tout petit peu cavalière
entre guillemets dans le sens législatif
du terme on n pas du tout parlé du parc
immobilier on est passé d'un certain
nombre de sites d'accueil qui qui a
fondu
mais certains d'ailleurs de ces sites on
y avait fait des travaux moi dans dans
mon département on avait mis à neuf ça
avait coûté des dizaines voire même plus
de milliers d'euros puis le site est
désormais inutilisé alors je suppose que
certains appartenaent à la DGFiP ou
DDFIP d'autres étaient peut-être loué je
pense que ce serait intéressant de
savoir est-ce que vous avez fait une
typologie à ce sujet est-ce que il y a
un parc immobilier utilisable re enfin
par le reste des administrations d'état
ou autre parce que enfin en tout cas
dans l'Oise il y a des bâtiments vides
et c'est bien
dommage merci merci Olivier bien je je
vais vous donner la la parole pour
quelques pour vos réponses euh et j'ai
peur que nos collègues finalement n pas
eu vraiment de questions mais ils
peuvent réagir à ce qu'ils ont entendu
bien entendu puis demander à
l'administration et et à la cour le
réaction avec je je vais me permettre de
de faire un bémol si vous me permettez
en disant n vous étonnez pas trop que
les sénateurs entendent d'abord ceux qui
se plaignent d'une certaine façon plus
que ceux qui vont bien c'est comme c'est
c'est c'est c'est comme toujours je veux
dire par là que ce ceux qui bon ceux qui
sont peutêtre pas satisfaits de la
réforme enfin en tout cas qui vivent
avec sans trop de difficulté bon
s'exprime assez peu et on entend souvent
comme toujours ceux qui ont des
difficultés bon c'est c'est un peu la
règle du jeu et ça ça permet de de de
nuancer de nuancer l'ensemble des propos
après moi j'ai une une remarque que j'ai
je l'ai souvent faite d'ailleurs à des
collègues quand il y a eu au moment de
d'ailleurs de la proposition de
réforme et puis par la suite c'est que
il y a quelquefois confusion entre
l'amélioration ou le maintien d'une
qualité de service public c'est qui
quand même la base pour l'administration
essayer on lui demande à la fois d'avoir
uneist une administration moins chère et
à la fois de maintenir une qualité de de
prestation on le sait tous surtout en
commission des finances ici euh et en
même temps le sujet qui est ce qu'on
appelle le recul des services publics
qui en fait traduit plutôt dans
certaines commune le le le fait
que après la poste quelques classes et
cetera c'est un recul en fait du nombre
de salariés du service public vous voyez
dans les communes ce qui crée des des
difficultés c'est-à-dire que dans des
villages qui ont déjà du mal à tenir
quelquefois parce qu'ils ont une
activité économique faible et ben le
retrait le retrait de service public
c'est aussi le retrait de famille et et
donc ça crée effectivement un un
sentiment mais en réalité le refus n'est
pas le refus de la réforme parce que euh
comment dire la modernité parce que le
numérique et cetera qui peut être
compris mais parce que ça a des
retombées qui font que si on enlève
trois personnes ici sur la trésorerie
qu'on enlève trois personnes ou quatre à
la poste ben à la fin il y a moins
d'enfants dans l'école donc ça ferme une
classe puis et cetera et cetera donc
c'est cet enchaînement là qui est mal
vécu je je le crois au moins autant que
la question de savoir si le service est
rendu pas rendu et cetera et moi j'ai
été maire il y a quelques années
maintenant mais moi je jamais entendu
parler de enfin je veux dire la
population me demandait jamais de garder
une trésorerie c'était pas le sujet fa
franchement ben en même temps trésorerie
c'était pas vu comme comment dire un
service public passionnant quoi bon
voilà bon faut se donc il y a eu des
inversions mais qui sont liées à ça hein
qui qui sont aussi liés à ça voilà je
crois que c'est pour un peu ça n'enlève
pas ça n'enlève pas la réalité de de
réaction et et et de problèmes qui sont
plus d'ailleurs comme souvent
effectivement le fait de de qualité des
personnes qui les mettent en œuvre quoi
bon voilà mais c'est vrai dans la vie
c'est vrai dans dans toutes les
fonctions y compris les fonctions
sénatoriales il y a voilà il y a les
sénateurs qui passent bien il y a les
sénateur qui F et cetera voilà c'est
comme ça et et et et donc il y a tout ça
prendre en compte dans vos réponses
alors si vous voulez nous apporter par
rapport à ce que vous avez entendu un
commentaire plus qu'une réponse
finalement à des questions puisquil y a
pas eu de questions qui soit tourné
réellement vers vous mais évidemment je
vous donne la parole avec plaisir la
coberti oui merci Monsieur le le le
président enfin je rebondirai sur un
point effectivement nos concitoyens de
la même façon que les collectivités
membres voire même les EPCI ont besoin
du service après qu'il y ait
une localisation physique du service à
tel ou tel endroit je dirais peu importe
d'ailleurs dans nos mairies ce qui était
extrêmement prisé par le passé c'était
au moment de la déclaration d'impôt le
rendez-vous possible en mairie avec
l'inspecteur des impôts de l'époque et
il faut absolument
redonner cette qualité de proximité du
service ça c'est
fondamental
merci Monsieur juste un petit mot je vis
dire que j'étais heureux d'entendre que
pas mal de ressentis d'un certain nombre
de vos collègues par rapport à ce que
nous on ressent sur le terrain le
mal-être de beaucoup de M qui sont donc
vraiment il y a beaucoup de m en
particulier en milieu rural qui ont
besoin d'être accompagné dans dans les
différents domaines en particulier dans
le domaine des finances parce que c'est
quand même le nerf de la guerre et donc
là-dessus c'est vrai qu'il faut je red
redis tout de suite plus plus de
pédagogie des documents plus clairs et
peut-être des contacts même s'ils sont
pas très souvent une fois une fois par
an qu'on a un contact c'est c'est c'est
important et vraiment si on peut
améliorer
l'accompagnement de mes collègues sur le
terrain ça serait quand même bien et si
ça cette réunion peut y contribuer ben
merci à tous ceux qui ont organisé Cour
des comptes le Sénat et la DG FIP bien
sûr merci Monsieur le Maire Monsieur le
Directeur en quelques en quelques
minutes
maintenant quelques réponses
merci monsieur le Président c'est le
plus grand défi de la matinée c'est
quelques minutes pour répondre j'ai
compté à 32 questions talentueux voilà
vous venez de perdre 15 secondes voilà
c'est fait exprès c'est fait exprès et
certaines pourrai justifier comme la
vôre monsieur monsieur le sénateur plus
que quelques secondes je vais je vais je
donc je présente d'ors et déjà donc les
mes excuses pour celles et ceux qui
considérerai que mes réponses so sont
soit inexistantes soit expéditives mais
je vais essayer de me couler il est à
votre il est à votre disposition madame
et de même que je je réponds avec
plaisir par avance à une invitation am
moiselle et euh dans le en HauteGaronne
et où vous souhaiterez par
ailleurs non non non non monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur j'ai d'abord j'y
suis déjà allé et ensuite ça sera
forcément avec plaisir quelques éléments
merci monsieur le Président pour ce que
vous avez dit j'étais euh pas très
inquiet on ne perd jamais à écouter le
retour euh retour du terrain donc merci
à chacune et chacun d'entre vous pour ce
que vous nous avez dit de nous-mêmes et
ce que vous nous avez indiqué et
renvoyé quelques éléments un peu
généraux puis ensuite de plus en plus
précis plusieurs d'entre vous ont parlé
des sujets de ressources humaines il est
impossible un responsable
administratif quand il est auditionné à
la représentation nationale
de d'avoir une réponse totalement
confortable sur la question des moyens
les moyens mes moyens c'est vous qui me
les donnez et j'essaie de faire au mieux
ou au moins mal avec ce que vous me
donnez
euh et je répète ce que j'avais dit en
introduction ils ont été diminux de 40 %
en 22 en 25 ans ce qui est beaucoup et
je pense que les résultats globaux de
l'action de cette maison n'ont pas été
diminués de dans les mêmes proportions
pendant la même période et ça on le doit
à l'engagement quotidien des agents qui
la composent je je voulais commencer par
le rappeler ensuite est-ce que ils vont
dans les endroits les plus les plus
ruraux qui sont ceux qui ont été
fréquemment évoqué par les uns et les
autres à l'instant
oui pas assez et vous avez parlé des
difficultés des secrétaires de mit
fondamentalement la sociologie est très
voisine et les difficultés sont
identiques on a du mal à convaincre et
on n'a pas nécessairement les moyens de
forcer les agents à aller dans des
endroits qu'ils ne veulent pas euh enfin
dans lesquels pardon ils ne veulent pas
aller et lorsque tel agent est affecté à
telle structure il n'y a pas
d'obligation d'y habiter et ça on
imagine particulièrement mal qu'on le
lui impose et donc ce que vous disiez
monsieur le Président sur le fait que
parfois euh la fermeture d'un service
entraîne le départ de famille
malheureusement ce n'est pas vrai et
l'un des constats que nous avions fait
était que les postes des petites
trésoreries les plus euh dans les
endroits les plus les plus éloignés des
grands centres urbains étaient par
généralement celles et ceux qui étaient
les moins attractifs pour nos agents
nous avions beaucoup de mal à les y
affecter nous avions beaucoup de mal à
les y maintenir et donc à assurer un
niveau enfin non seulement de la
présence mais ensuite un service de
qualité dans la durée avec des
interlocuteurs stabilisés ce qui est la
nécessité de la qualité du service sujet
qu'on rencontre directement me
semble-t-il
de de vos retours et de quelques
expériences professionnelles ou
personnelles avec les secrétaires de
mairie
aussi créer des services plus densifiés
qui assurent pardon pour la terminologie
le backoffice financier comptable assure
une durée et un niveau de service public
de qualité dans la durée ce que des
équipes très petites trop petites à la
merci de du moindre pin de santé d'un
agent ne pouvait pas assurer dans la
durée
vous avez vous avez été plusieurs à
m'interpell sur les délais de paiement à
ce sujet deux choses avant le covid
délai de paiement des collectivités
locales 25 jours aujourd'hui 26
jours ça c'est un niveau national ça
cache évidemment des disparités des
disparités à la hausse que vous avez
montré et des disparités à la baisse qui
existent aussi et qu'il faut avoir en
tête et le délai c'est 25 jours entre le
moment
où le le prestataire de service a
adressé sa facture à la collectivité et
le moment où où il est payé je rappelle
ça parce que quand on parle des des
dépassements enfin d'abord les délais de
paiement public sont très inférieurs au
délais de de paiement interentreprise
euh c'est un élément qu'il faut pardon
ne jamais perdre de vue la consigne est
donnée au directeurs départementaux des
finances publiques de veiller à ce que
lorsqu'il y a un décalage un dérapage
dans le délai de paiement
euh émanant d'une collectivité locale
qui est une prise de contact avec euh
les élus ou l'administration de la
commune en question pour identifier
quelle est la nature du problème si
cette prise de contact est pas
intervenue de manière spécifique dans
les cas de figure que vous avez
mentionné portez-le à l'attention du
Directeur départemental des finances
publiques ou à la mienne pour qu'on
regarde ce qui se
passe vous avez parlé de de quelques cas
euh de euh d'exigen démesuré euh ou de
de
potillisme euh absurde je les entends
ils existent c'est pas ce que je demande
à mes
agents néanmoins si on je pense que si
on fait l'effort collectif de regarder
la situation je ne suis pas certain que
la totalité des exigences
subitesf
soit un objectif de de super surqualité
et que nous prenons aussi parfois les
informations que nous avons et celles
que nous n'avons pas la qualité des
comptes des collectivités elle est
variable et les sujets d'imputation
comptable les sujets de présence d'une
pièce justificative ou pas et de respect
minimaux ou standard des règles de la
commande publique sont observés de
manière on va dire différent dans les
endroits les sujets de besoins de
formation des secréire deie que vous
avez mentionné peuvent en être une cause
les différentiels de pratique aussi
et j'ai nettoyé chez moi et je ne suis
pas sûr que lorsque j'aurais terminé de
nettoyer chez moi ce qui peut prendre du
temps la totalité du ménage aura été
terminé pour dire les choses un peu
rapidement sur les sujets de
l'implantation vous avez beaucoup parlé
de France service à à cet égard deux
sujets le premier j'entends les
critiques je pense que c'est un grand
succès des années récente en matière de
capacité à assurer et à développer un
niveau de service public dans les
territoires j'ai souvenir d'avoir été
auditionné par une mission parlementaire
composée d'un sénateur et d'une députée
qui avait des des qui mettaiit en exerg
un bilan très positif et pas globalement
positif du dispositif et qui proposait
des éléments pour améliorer la qualité
nous la DG FIP on est membre du
dispositif depuis le début on y croit ça
nous permet d'avoir une finesse de
contact avec les contribuables supérieur
à celle qui celle qui existaient
auparavant je je vous indique pour que
vous le l'ayez en tête et que vous le
partagez avec avec les maires que nous
sommes il y en a beaucoup euh nous
sommes prêts à mettre en place des
points de contact avec la population en
dehors des fransices et en dehors de nos
de nos guichets dans les mairies
notamment je rappelle à cet égard deux
points euh néanmoins le premier c'est
que notre activité d'interrelation avec
le le grand public elle est
fondamentalement saisonnière euh pendant
la période où on déclare les revenus euh
et donc en dehors des saisons
d'activités fortes c'est pas la peine de
demander à avoir quelqu'un de chez nous
qui vient parce que il aura personne et
vous nous permettrez de d'essayer de
faire en sorte de prioriser
les endroits et les points de
rendez-vous dans lesquels il y a
beaucoup de monde qui vient plutôt qu'il
y a peu de monde je n'ai pas tant de
ressources que cela et envoyer un de mes
agents dans un endroit où il reçoit soit
personne soit une personne sur une
matinée quand dans le guichet on reçoit
100 200 300 personnes par heure il y a
un sujet d'allocation de moyens et vous
vous plaindriez avec raison de fait
qu'on fait beaucoup trop la queue trop
longtemps dans les points de guichet
parce qu'on a dispersé des effectifs
dans les endroits où ils avaient moins
besoin d'être et et j'ai je suis aussi
en charge d'assurer cette cette
hiérarchisation là le filet de
sécurité la prévision comme disait un
grand philosophe est un art difficile
surtout quand elle concerne l'avenir et
les les moments où on a figé les
dates pour
les faire entrer les les collectivités
dans le dispositif l'année n'était pas
terminée le volume de consommation
électrique et les montants payés
facturés étaient par définition inconnu
en tout cas dans leur dans leur
précision et dans leur exhaustivité on
avait prévu 416 millions d'euros de
filet de sécurité on a payé 400 millions
je crois que c'est ça l'ORD de grandeur
ça n faer 4 % d'erreur c'est beaucoup
mais c'est quand
même peu
considérable et il y a d'autres sujets
qui ont mis en exerg des variations
nettement plus
fortes Banque Postale
buraliste les buralistes c'est vrai donc
ils sont ouverts plus longtemps que chez
nous euh ils sont verts le samedi le
dimanche ils sont ouverts tard
l'après-midi moi je pense que c'est un
grand succès euh en terme de de
démultiplication d'offres en terme aussi
de capacité à
euh à permettre au contribuables d'aller
dans des endroits qu'il connaissent et
euh c ça rentre dans une logique
d'élargissement des types de missions
qui sont conf qui sont confé au buralis
qui qui est assez cohérent je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails de d' certain
de situations contra actuel les ordres
de grandeur que vous avez donné sont un
peu exagéré quo que pas très loin de la
quoi que proche de la de la réalité j'ai
entendu je crois monsieur monsieur le ma
Oberti dire qu'il avait qu'il fallait
réfléchir à des alternatives ou à des
éléments en plus des buralistes moi j'y
suis prêt effectivement c'est à chaque
fois des marchés publics
euh c'est donc l'argent de des habitants
de vos collectivités et le vôtre qui est
concerné par sa
dépense la commission des finances ne me
pardonnerait pas de le gaspiller de
manière peu efficiente mais si il y a
moyen de faire plus intelligent que ce
que nous faisons naturellement c'est
avec plaisir la Banque Postale on est en
préparation de renégociation avec
eux là je dirais que le bilan est
globalement
positif il y a moyen de l'améliorer des
entreprises en France qui ont la
capacité d'apporter un service
uniformisé sur tout le
territoire de gestion de flux financiers
et qui sont prêts à le faire et à s'y
engager il y en a pas il y en a pas
beaucoup donc il faut faire avec ce
qu'on souhaite et avec ce qu'on nous
donne et avec ce que l'État paye pour ce
service rendu aux collectivités
locales et j'essaie de faire au moins
mal avec ce triangle de contrainte et on
va donc rentrer dans une nouvelle
démarche contractuelle je trouve que le
dispositif en place présente des fact
des points d'amélioration c'est certain
mais aussi des éléments de solidité de
de garantie de solidité de pérénité
qu'il faut mesurer avant de le critiquer
trop fortement néanmoins
euh plusieurs d'entre vous ont parlé des
révision des valeurs locatives c'est
vrai que la révision des locaux
commerciaux c'est compliqué celle des
locaux d'habitation qui n'a jamais été
engagé depuis 1970 et qui a défaut
d'avoir des éléments de grande
simplicité se sont traduits l'année
dernière par une augmentation des bases
de 7 %
euh de manière automatique je sais pas
si c'est simple en tout cas c'est euh
plus ça va plus c'est un un mécanisme
qui est daté daté dans ces effets avec
des effets de redistribution qui sont
assez
improbables tout de même et euh dont
l'évolution sur son air peut me
semble-t-il soulever dans un avenir euh
incertain mais pas forcément lointain un
sujet de compréhension d'acceptation de
l'impôt dans les modalités de calcul et
dans son montant et je ne parle pas des
décisions qui relèvent de la vibre
administration des collectivités
d'augmenter les taux mais je parle juste
de l'évolution des bases qui en sur en
202 entre 2023 à 2024 aura été
extrêmement importante extrêmement forte
beaucoup plus que euh la plupart des
autres impôts monsieur le Président dans
la limite du temps qui est imparti je
peux m'arrêter là je peux vous parler
d'intelligence artificielle la direction
générale desffence publicique mais ça
peut durer longtemps je vous préviens
par avance merci merci beaucoup Monsieur
le Directeur madame la
présidente monsieur le Président je vais
essayer d'être très Brè moi aussi parce
que je pense que beaucoup de questions
viennent d'être traitées il y a eu des
compléments d'information
importants je voudrais revenir peut-être
sur les recommandations qui sont faites
dans le rapport par la Cour et notamment
sur le bilan des conseillers aux
décideurs locaux parce qu'il me semble
que les différentes questions et
témoignages qui viennent d'être apportés
montre qu'il y a vraiment besoin d'un
bilan très fin très territorialisé de ce
dispositif le risque c'est de faire
quelque chose de très global avec des
moyennes et cetera or on voit bien que
d'un endroit à l'autre les besoins
diffèent les personnes diffèrent ça a
été dit et euh même si dispositif dans
son principe est salué l'idée c'est
qu'il continue de se déployer dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et une
des interrogation que que nous avons
c'est plutôt pour l'avenir parce que il
faudra pouvoir continuer à assurer à
travers le le renouvellement des
conseillers au décideurs locaux le même
niveau de qualité sur vous l'avez dit
des questions qui peuvent être très
diverses et des attentes qui sont très
vaste de la part des élus et aussi de
péréniser dans le temps ce dispositif
peut-être en
redéployant localement plus de CDL ou
moins dans certains endroits enfin on
voit bien que là le le besoin d'un bilan
très fin est vraiment important sur la
participation aux espaces francesice je
pense qu'effectivement il faut être
attentif au besoins al leors sais alité
ça vient d'être dit cela dit c'est un
dispositif qui monte en puissance je
veux pas faire d'annonce tout de suite
mais enfin à la cour nous avons une
évaluation en cours de ce dispositif et
je pense que quand les résultats seront
connus ce sera tout à fait intéressant
peut-être d'y revenir et il est certain
que dans ce domaine il
faut améliorer là O aussi le niveau de
de réponse péréniser la qualité revoir
peut-être la carte des implantations ça
dépasse le cadre strict du du rapport
bien sûr mais ça met en lumière à la
fois les les attentes qui sont très
fortes parce que le dispositif est
plutôt réussi comme cela a été dit et
donc ça pose forcément de de nouvelles
questions sur l'éectronisme notamment
c'était pas forcément une mission
initiale des maisons Fran service mais
je voudrais juste rappeler un chiffre
puisque la la question a été posée tout
à l'heure d'après la Défenseur des
droits il y a quand même 10 millions de
personnes en France qui souffrent
d'électronisme c'est-à-dire qui ont des
difficultés d'accès au service numérique
donc voilà
donc donc c'est c'est quand même une
question qu'on ne peut pas contourner
euh il faut il faut la traiter bon bien
sûr c'est pas la la dég FIB toute seule
qui va répondre à ce besoin je pense que
on en est tous conscient mais néanmoins
c'est un besoin qui se cristallise dans
les accueils France service sur la la
dernière recommandation la satisfaction
des usagers bon je pense que c'est une
une recommandation importante aussi on
l'a dit ça c'est c'est lié d'ailleurs au
au point préc
mais je pense que il y a peut-être aussi
on l'a pas dit mais la satisfaction des
élus donc on l'a mesuré ponctuellement
au cours de l'enquête je pense que dans
le cadre du bilan qui doit être fait il
faudra continuer bien sûr à être très
attentif sur ce point voilà monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais vous indiquer que dans le
compte-rendu nous
joindrons une note de l'AMF qui est une
réponse PCE également quelques quelques
éléments de d'appréciation de
l'Association des Maes de France sur ce
rapport de la Cour des comptes il ne
pouvait pas être là ce matin il s'en
excuse euh monsieur le rapporteur
spécial quelques mots de synthèse
peut-être oui euh en vous remerciant en
vous remerciant aussi d'avoir euh
d'avoir saisi nous avoir proposé de
saisir la Cour des comptes sur ce sujet
je crois qu' était tout à fait tout à
fait intéressant je vous remercie
monsieur le Président d'avoir accepté de
proposer au premier président de la Cour
des comptes ce sujet qui intéresse
beaucoup les sénateurs certes euh trois
observations rapides pour le nouveau
réseau de proximité j'ai connu comme mes
collègues parce que les avis sont
contrastés euh des craintes des maires
je Dir en 2019 2020 quand on leur dit on
va fermer votre trésorerie dans votre
commune bien sûr ensuite aussi l'inconnu
comment ça va se passer et et et là si
j'ai dis que le GL le bilan était
globalement positif c'est que il s'est
passé c'est quand même 4 ans et que les
choses euh donc ont évolué tout
simplement parce que les craintes ont
été dissipées et puis les maires se sont
rendus compte que ils créaient surtout
pour eux pour leur budget
mais comme m'a dit un maire mais il y a
un nouveau couple qui est venu
s'installer dans ma commune il m'a
demandé s'il y avait un médecin il m'a
demandé s'il y avait une école il m'a
demandé où était le supermarché il m'a
Jama demandé s'il y avait une trésorerie
ben je Madame la Maire vous m'aviez dit
pique pendre sur tout ce que il allit se
passer quand on a a dit que votre
trésorerie où il y avait trois personnes
à les fermer donc ah bah oui mais bon ça
s'est bien passé voilà quand je dis
positif je résume un peu à travers cette
anecdote
donc différent le prisme et mais le
prisme des sénateurs c'est aussi notre
corp électoral bon ça il faut le
comprendre mais euh les habitants des
communes non'ont pas forcément la même
approche que que les que les
Maes deè
euh sujet donc là c'est un constat
partagé c'est bien sûr la le cadastre
bon c'est vrai que on en a parlé mais
j'ai pas ressenti des des réponses
précises Monsieur le Directeur donc je
pense que la DG FIP est suffisamment
puissante et suffisamment intelligente
et compétente pour pouvoir régler
problème une bonne fois pour toutes il y
a un travail de titan c'est vrai mais il
faut bien le faire et comme on dit
familièrement ce qui est fait n'est plus
à faire donc si vous pouviez vous y
atteler une bonne fois pour toutes et
puis après on n parle plus bah c'est pas
tous les jours qu'il va falloir tout
remettre d' plomb mais il y a un certain
retard dans certaines communes il y a
peut-être 30 ans 40 ans o le cas là sera
faux et dernier point démérialisation là
je crois que là aussi le constat est
partagé il faut vraiment accompagner
les personnes qu'on appelle publiquement
en précarité numérique souvent sont des
personnes âgées tout le monde ne s'y met
pas tout le monde ne veut pas s'y mettre
et donc c'est pas des sous citoyens ce
sont pas des sous citoyens il faut que
la DG FIP comprenne que ce sont des
citoyens comme les autres et et qui
méritent le respect et et donc il faut
s'adapter et là les maires aussi sont
les premiers interlocuteurs de ces gensl
dans les petites communes voilà en
résumé monsieur le Président donc et je
vous remercie d'avoir appuyé ce cette
proposition merci à la Cour des comptes
également de M associer de s déplacé
vous avez choisi deux départements je
crois la C Marne pour le le urbain et la
corise pour le département rural c'est
c'est un très bon choix et je vous
félicite
merci merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
après vous je vais remercier madame la
Présidente et l'ensemble de ses
collègues de la Cour des comptes bien
sûr ici présent Monsieur le Directeur
Magnan et nos collègues des associations
d'élus merci à vous je vais vous
demander de rester 30 secondes de plus
vous allez assister à un des travaux les
plus importants de la commission qui est
la désignation de rapporteur vous allez
voir euh simplement simplement
simplement vous ne pourrez pas
voter mais c'est tout alors euh donc je
vous propose mes chers collègues